Hi, Maibu.
Hi, everybody.
Hello.
Welcome and welcome.
Welcome, welcome.
I am once again playing Crime Scene Cleaner because I like
this game.
I can really welcome back and Koki, welcome.
minke hello hello hello hello hi oh my gosh i was gonna play
a different game today and then when i was making my
schedule yesterday i was thinking of all the work that i had
to do today which i got some of it done most of it done i
got most of it done and i i i um was like oh you know what
This game, I've been enjoying it so much.
Sorry that I've been playing it so often.
But I was like, I'm going to reward myself with this game.
Marco!
Thank you so much for the part, Guthrie!
I was like, if I get most or all of my work done, I will
reward myself with this game.
So here we are back.
Do you guys notice that the seed just went off the monitor?
Like the whole logo.
Okay.
But hey, thank you so much for that part, get it.
Hello, Minta and Ibo's like you just got off at no spilling,
no spilling.
Long paint factory and was painting in a color called Mint
Condition.
I thought of you.
What are you obsessed with me or something?
I was gonna Oshikats, but I forgot my little Vicky.
Maybe bringing her to work could be a hazard, especially if
you're paint spilling.
You can clean crime scenes all you want to, thank you
actually what was it happy september guess who has a
birthday in one month me or you if you're having fun we're
also having fun who doesn't love ketchup so true good
morning veto good morning veto yes and one happy september
everybody in one month exactly my birthday my birthday if
you put if you wait if what oh my gosh sorry if i put you in
a bottle of coke would it explode that's that's that's
that's like a mentos no what are mentos even made of that
allow that to happen i wonder wake me up when it ends am i
right well don't it's fine it's like i was thinking about
this the other day i feel like september is feels like the
start of fall even though it is or rather no sorry august
feels like it's the start of fall so wait no sorry september
september october november even though it's the end of
september that should be that's technically the start of
fall i mean though i love you i love you thank you so i feel
like I know it's like a solstice thing or whatever, but I
feel like it should be as soon as September starts.
You know?
If you want to see a certain writer's VA, watch Mel Brooks
Robin Hood.
He's a nut!
Missed awake.
It's still hot here though.
I mean, yes, it's still hot, but...
vibes.
It's all vibes, right?
The meteorological, meteorological autumn.
Meteorological.
That was my birthday yesterday!
Thanks for closing the May Cafe for me specifically.
Karina, it's a happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
I mean, I love Amelia in the big 2026.
I mean, though, yesterday was my The person goes!
Happy birthday!
I was gonna say something earlier.
Hold on.
Oh, wait.
I've gotten so sidetracked from my thoughts, thought
processes of what I was gonna talk about.
Oh, there it goes to see.
It went off the screen.
You saw it?
yeah about autumn yeah I think it's just vibes I don't know
something about September feel I mean I know like I said I
know end of September is technically it but it should be the
beginning hi Mito I love Mito hi Gapo I love me I don't know
the days will get cooler the days will get shorter so
everybody carry flashlights because the darkness is scary
it's scary but I'm excited fall fall and my birthday oh I've
been working on birthday stuff all day today no yesterday
yesterday I got so much birthday stuff done I got so much
birthday stuff done today I didn't get so much birthday
stuff done just a little bit of birthday stuff done hot dog
indeed oh wait one second sorry it's one of those types of
games where i click out of it and it stops the music vod
watcher been a while since my last dono thanks paul a
tribute for the great announcement it was amazing wait what
wait what is this
uh six slick wists okay i hate this i'm not i'm not saying
this Does that remind me of?
It reminds you of Danny DeVito.
The irony I just got off my shift and I'm a housekeeper.
But you were not cleaning up bodies, were you?
I hope not.
I hope not, maybe.
Unless?
Hot dog.
Hot dog!
Today is not my birthday successfully defended my thesis so
apparently I have a PhD now congratulations dr. pirate five
lots to celebrate today lots to celebrate today um man there
was something I was gonna mention earlier I think it was
about like the games that I was playing I was like oh I'm
playing this a lot um I next week I think next week i think
i was like yeah we can do it next week um but i told berry
bug well berry bug asked me and she was like do you want to
play halo co-op i was like i've never played halo before so
yeah i do and um and so we'll be doing that yes yes yes so
quite a few things a few things uh because so i'm trying to
like you know what's the word free up some games slots is
what i'm trying to say so i'll do a lot of crime scene
cleaner free up some game slots and then have halo and
control and other stuff yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah sorry
i missed your concert isn't too much pain since surgery oh
and folks i hope you're feeling better six weeks since the
operation I'm starting to feel better.
I'm glad.
Get lots of rest.
Long time.
Super chatter.
First time viewer.
Minto fan for all time.
Wow.
A first time.
And you're already a fan for all time.
Wow.
Thank you, Leaning Tower.
She said yes.
To what?
Me?
She said yes.
Happy September, Minto.
As a reward for doing my work.
I'll watch Minto play clean game as a reward for doing her
work.
Thank you.
It's quite a little bit.
literally it.
Minto, I just bought MGS Master Collection 2.
Can't wait to experience Peace Walker in 4 for the first
time.
Oh my gosh, Bronsaw, you got this.
I want to play 4 so bad.
Like, obviously I have the Master Collection.
I'm just so...
Hmm.
Minto, cute.
Thank you.
I just haven't had time.
It's been a lot.
Probably after this month I'll have more time.
I keep saying that.
But after this month, then I'll have no more birthday.
I'll have no more concerts.
It will be smooth sailing.
Yeah.
You've been saying that all year.
I know, right?
Last birthday ever.
For the year, yeah.
We can keep talking, though, as I clean.
Yes.
At least you have a manager to look at your schedules, too.
Yeah.
It's, like, a lot, still.
Like, sometimes, even he will forget.
Like, sometimes starter will be like, oh, yeah.
You guys need to do this thing.
And we're like, oh, okay.
I applied to a bunch of jobs lately.
Wish me luck also.
MGS Master Collection 2 in Delta now.
Let's go!
Come on, Joshua!
You can get a job!
You got this, you got this!
You're so capable.
Yeah, so sometimes Densetsu were like, Oh!
Okay.
We got to do the things.
We got to do the stuff.
Oh.
I'm stretching?
Minto hi, Minto.
Hello!
Hello, hello.
I think last time I couldn't find my dog.
Somewhere around here probably.
And let's see what the last...
Uh, e.
I was like, hello?
Let's see this one.
Oh, that's right!
It was like a...
like a fancy place.
Nothing too... nothing too interesting.
Just, yeah.
Dexter was missing.
Yeah!
She lost her invisible dog.
Coming up on one year of Densetsu 2?
Yes, yes.
We do have things planned for that.
Yes, yes, yes.
I think...
Yeah, we got stuff planned for that.
Uh...
It is wild that we're coming up on a year already, isn't it?
But...
I do...
I think because my birthday is mostly, you know, solo.
What is happening?
Why are my lights going out?
And my cup is shaking.
What is happening?
Why did my lights go out?
I think I hit the...
Oh, my house is haunted for real!
Hey!
What is going on?
I'm just freaking out.
What's happening?
You guys are seeing all this, right?
Oh, this is my bedroom.
This is it.
There's Dexter!
Pay your bails.
I paid my rent today.
Did you download a different game?
We're playing this super spooky version.
Affair with death.
Now this is quite out there, isn't it?
We've been in kind of in the city this whole time, but this
time we're getting 12,000 bucks too.
Okay, thank you so much for the time.
Gifted, thank you.
I'm haunting my own home.
He says that every night.
Didn't know he had a cameo.
Affair with death.
I don't know at which point it started to become mundane,
but I do remember All I was thinking about was, at least it
wasn't me who was being put in a bag.
So true.
Don't panic, but there's a ghost at the bottom right.
Wow.
Time to look for the bodies.
Watch this.
Axe throwing.
Happy September!
Cut back from attending a wedding.
Attending a wedding and relaxing, but now I've been doing
that new Peace Walker grind times five.
Switch one to Xbox, PlayStation Steam while having fun
watching you clean.
Good luck, Jakai doll!
You know you take one item back from each place?
Guess what you brought back from the cat lady, right?
Aw, thank you.
I had an interview one hour ago.
Good luck, man!
Thanks for always believing in us.
Of course I believe in you guys.
Because...
You guys watch me, you must have amazing taste and thoughts.
Maybe the poor boy has a key on him.
That's how I think.
I don't know what this does.
I'm just pressing buttons.
Holy fuck.
A bloodbath.
Oh, there goes all the blood.
Maybe I should have looked at it first.
The pool was completely entirely red.
Yes, we have great taste.
Exactly, exactly.
That's what I'm saying.
Flamingo.
Well.
Let's take a look around first.
I like to observe the surroundings.
Would you consider watching the greatest show of all time?
Ghost adventures for Halloween!
It'd be a Minto stream for the ages.
I do love me some ghost adventures.
Zach Baggins is so funny.
What's going on here?
Incognito mode.
Is that bug spray?
I guess you would need it if you're out here.
What's he doing on here?
I didn't know that's how incognito mode worked.
Only- it only works for your special- for- like, recognizes
the special eyes.
Okay, this place isn't- I mean it's big but it is not so
much to clean as I thought.
For now.
He's on Damboru!
I go on there for inspiration all the time.
Oh, well.
That's a lot of trash.
Oh, so close.
Yeah, sure.
What are you talking about?
Why would I lie about that?
Why would I lie?
Wait, what is it?
It's four, okay.
Why would I lie?
Of course, I go on there for, like, outfit inspiration.
I just have to weed out the...
That's where he was shot.
for the first time.
Managed to walk a few steps and fell into the water.
I have to weed out the, uh, you know.
No.
Oh, yeah.
Might be worth something.
It's cash.
Weed out the what?
I'm living.
You know.
Ooh.
The boobs.
Won't budge.
Looks like some kind of electronic look.
Oh, interesting.
You ain't weeding out nothing.
Don't lie.
Be proud.
I'm not gonna send, you know, I know Mama is used to it, but
I'm not sending her...
I'm not sending her 18 plus images for my references.
Because I'm afraid she might actually do it.
She might actually...
Where's the lock then?
She would.
I believe.
I missed the part where that's a problem.
I missed the part where that's my problem.
Wait, how the heck am I supposed to get inside here?
I'm not that kind of YouTuber, you guys.
So fun meeting you all kind many moments ago.
I was one of the dancing mids.
Thank you!
So cute!
You guys dance so cute!
Thank you, thank you!
Thanks for coming to see me.
Speaking of bugs, Bray, do you know what's happening with
Matara?
Huh?
Uh, she didn't sound great in her last post.
I hope no one's gone at her with the raid.
Oh, no, I've talked to Matara.
She's okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Sending your mama 18 plus references.
You are turning 19 again soon.
I took your newie with me to see Paranormal activity on
Broadway Oh my gosh, Chie, I'm so jealous If you come back
to NYC before the play ends I highly recommend it, it's very
scary I heard that I actually heard that the paranormal
activities Like I keep seeing videos on it And I keep
hearing that the stage play Like people are obviously trying
not to spoil it But they'll be like I've been getting videos
on where to sit To have the best like experience and stuff.
It's not a musical.
It is like just a stage play, but I've heard it's
legitimately good.
Like, actually.
Oh, I want to see it so bad, because there's a lot of not
audience participation, but they kind of involve the
audience a little bit.
Which is like the perfect thing for a spooky...
Whoa, why am I lagging?
Oh, My computer's been acting really funky today.
Like watching a 4D movie.
Right, right, right.
You leave anything running?
No.
There.
One second.
Oh!
Wait.
I've liked that before.
I didn't I think I think OBS changed my bit rate That's
funky Let me try this What the weird I wasn't that high
before I'm still lagging though Wait OBS like updated And I
kind of hate it to be honest Um I
Wait, uh?
Giga had a lot of her settings changed.
Yeah, like...
Wait, what?
But I played this game.
I didn't change any settings on this game before, or rather,
since I last played and I had no issues.
So it's not the game, but...
I'm very confused.
I have...
Why?
I think it's my computer.
Oh, man.
Why?
What the heck?
Sorry.
So sorry.
So sorry, guys.
It's going to be a long night.
What the...
No, V-Sync is on right there.
Yeah, maybe we'll just Chibi just so I can keep playing.
I'll figure it out later.
One second.
Oh, wait.
I'm frozen.
Wait, does that work?
I'm frozen?
Oh,
that's why.
Wait, one second.
I'm so sorry, guys.
One second.
Wee!
I have to reset some stuff.
No, no, no, no, no.
My camera's not working.
Ah, there we go.
Easy peasy.
Yeah, I don't know.
Weird.
I've been able to play this game like completely normal the
past couple of times.
So, Tim Tim, thank you so much.
Thank you.
Hmm.
Don't tell regular mint or lilac, but Chibi Minto is my
cameo.
Why?
Do I I don't think I'm lagging now.
I think we're okay.
What happened?
What's going on?
It's so frustrating when, like, I have the beefy computer
that I do, and yet so many issues continue to arise.
What's up?
Ah, there's the key!
Yoink?
Oh.
My bad.
Hold on.
Uh, there we go.
Ugh.
And yet!
And... Oh, no!
I'm back!
What is going on?
Keeps cleaning.
I don't care.
Maybe this level has a weird bug.
Maybe it is the level, right?
Actually, it is every time that I'm in here, right?
It's every time that I'm in here.
It's every time I'm in the pool, I start lagging.
Weird.
Very funny.
One year!
Weezing thank you!
The tile pattern.
Tiles are individually rendered.
Must be something like that.
Alright, well we'll finish up the pool and then we don't
have to go back in.
I've already changed the TV though.
We're stuck.
I've used all my spiritual energy to change for warm.
The PC is dropped.
It's like me actually throwing my PC in there.
I blame the video.
You can do that, but I have an AMD.
I have an AMD driver.
You could blame the video.
Yeah, let's still blame them.
Have you seen the new Ace Combat online preview?
Cool.
I can already imagine you, our flight leader, and all the
iBoo's on your side.
Have lots of fun to the co-op badges.
We will play together.
I'm excited.
Yeah.
We have Ace Combat in just a month, too.
Crazy.
It's like right after my birthday.
So happy birthday to me.
me oh oh i have you oh we got rid of all the trash nice
there is an evidence we are missing from the pool oh nice uh
and move all the furniture back ah oh i think the body is
the uh sorry we do have to go back into the pool
one shot in the back one in the head.
He didn't really stand the chance.
Yikes.
What the?
The way he died kind of reminds me of the Great Gatsby.
Now, if only they could release MGS 6 for your birthday.
Happy birthday to me!
We're just creating a whole new thing.
We're just, uh...
Oh, whoops, sorry.
I didn't mean to punch you.
We're just creating a whole new game.
Just for you.
No need to thank me.
My... I went to my sister's wedding Like near to a goal and
it reminds me of this place The venue that she had it at it
was a very strange location in the middle of nowhere And
then also had lots of statues around like this And lots of
stray cats And actually, there was a pool too, and then she
stood over here.
Maybe a short circuit would do the job.
Wait, oh, maybe it's this.
There we go.
What's in here?
Your sister study witchcraft?
Maybe.
My sister's very like...
I saw you two last night.
photos but your wife doesn't need to see him i just shut up
not here let's go inside she bought one affair too far mark
at one point she had bought a uh huge like how does that not
count as evidence like a really big plot of land it was my
birthday yesterday red sign happy birthday to celebrate
decided to finally match my name across my account so now i
am a rat Happy Raton-ing!
Happy birthday!
Galaxy, thank you.
I'm a lurker normally, but wanted to say thank you for your
fun streams.
I also started my last year's bachelors and wore my Minto
shirt to class, but no one recognized it.
Friends, yet.
You can introduce them.
Aw, well, thanks for wearing the shirt out.
Thank you.
her purchased like a really big plot of land that um that
should open the main door it originally like belonged to
like some i don't want to say a coven did the wedding frame
rate get really bad too whenever you used to play the fool
it might have she not a cult so like they had houses in the
trees definitely not up to code and you would go up the
houses and like one of them had like a huge theater and then
there was a big field in the middle of the forest that had
like it almost looked like what's it called
Stonehenge and and they would like perform rituals and stuff
there and uh your sister wanted this that's the kind of
person my sister is she they were she bought it with the
intention of continuing it
little little guys oh sorry yeah she doesn't own it anymore
um like they like you know I need you to know that is a
cult.
Well, I don't know.
Um, but, you know, so,
uh, like, there was a guy there, one of the guys that, like,
helped build the place.
Like, you know, I mean, they did have, they did, like, bury
him there in the middle of, or not in the middle of the
circle.
I don't know.
They did mention that, though.
She was, like, taking me on a tour of the place?
It was, like, an hour to walk around everything.
It was humongous.
It was, like, a huge chunk of land in the middle of nowhere.
So, like, was your sister a part of this coven?
I guess?
I don't know.
Oh, it was...
Yeah.
I don't know.
That's just my sister.
Okay.
This is getting scarier.
Is it?
Just my sister things.
Looks like I'll need to find a key.
I know I saw- oh there it is.
Just wanted to say my ghost hunt crew shipped yesterday.
Can't wait for it to get it.
Pizza thank you for ordering it!
I'm so sorry it took so long.
They have, they, Setsuna has told me that orders should not
nearly take as long as they had before.
Basically, things got so backlogged because they did not
have space in the warehouse.
Yeah, they moved into a new place, yes, yes.
So I'm really sorry that it took nearly a year to get some
of this stuff out.
But like, they legitimately had no space for anything,
apparently.
so it was a little tough for them.
Make it look nice and clean.
I can do that.
Oh, I thought that was a crab.
I was like, what's that guy doing there?
Hoping I get mine soon.
I want my silly slippers.
And again, if you ever want an update on your...
Is that the surveillance room?
What's the surveillance room?
Yeah, I was supposed to delete some footage or something.
If you ever want an update on your status of your order,
don't hesitate to email and be like, Hey, it's been a really
long time.
Please.
Can I please have an update?
You can even say, Minto told Minto.
Minto said, please, to give me an update.
Yeah.
My shirt finally shipped.
I'm so excited.
I'm excited for you.
to see people where yeah they do typically have good
communication it has been a busy time for us but I want you
know I joined I joined you know I could do everything by
myself but I joined Setsuna and we became Densetsu EXE to
have these things a little more streamlined right so of
course I want them to go well for you guys as well so I can
I can be like let's let's you know they obviously are
working on getting everything more worked out because they
moved and everything so it would be wild if you were doing
all the merch stuff too yeah I don't think I mean obviously
I don't I would need to work with somebody because I don't
know anything about production or like who i don't even who
i would reach out to yeah
how have you liked working with satsuna i've liked it yeah
it has made things much easier on i mean i'm busy her busier
but at the same time uh i'm busier in the sense that like
you know sometimes i would have to turn down opportunities
or If I was too busy.
And sometimes I also just didn't get opportunities.
Because I couldn't reach out, you know?
Because I didn't either have the time.
Or the knowledge of who to reach out to.
And I wasn't going to places and networking myself.
So now there's people to do that.
Why is there a chair in here?
So yeah.
So.
It is good in that regard.
Had to move before an order was fulfilled.
They were incredibly helpful and responsive in changing my
address.
Seriously, 10 out of 10 customer service.
Oh, that's good.
That's good.
I'm glad to hear that.
Thank you, Sji Brian.
Thank you.
I never beat Control, but now I have to beat it before you
to avoid spoilers.
It's good motivation.
Good luck, Robo.
Good luck.
Thanks for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm so excited for Mark Control.
Oh, my gosh.
I think...
I don't know.
Maybe next week I'll do it.
Well, next week is a little bit busy.
A week after I might do it twice.
In a week.
Or something.
Yeah, new control in a month.
There's going to be so...
Oh my gosh, there's so many games coming out.
Like, next month.
There's so many games coming out next month.
Like, actually.
It's so crazy.
Okay.
There we go.
So busy until GTA 6.
I can't tell if people are excited for GTA 6 or not.
I honestly haven't been looking at the reception of people.
I know the game, like, got leaked or something.
No, I'm not.
Oh, no.
Oh, baby, all right.
I heard something about it, like, being released at launch
at 30 FPS.
And that made me be like, huh?
Huh?
What?
So, I was like, wait.
This feels not great.
4PS 5!
The normies are coming.
You guys are funny.
The normies are excited.
They can have their cods in there.
In there.
Oh.
What's the words?
Their GTAs.
Yeah, I know a lot of people do like the the GTA RP stuff.
So Hmm.
This is gross.
Is it?
Wait.
Yes, it's gross.
It's gross.
They don't know about crime scene cleaner.
They're sleeping on peak!
I'm telling you!
Don't worry about the frame drops in the pool.
Just don't go in the pool!
They don't know!
One time Larker just figured I'd hope... Wait, I...
I've just figured I'd hope say you missed a spot oh yeah i'm
working on it don't worry don't worry i bought fuminto a
while ago and now the spot i left for her has been occupied
with other merch it's also so big i have no idea what where
she'll go when she arrives where do you put plushies that
big okay i have this thing hold on let me see actually i'm
gonna try and find a picture of it because i will i will
teach you IKEA what's it called table
okay so I there's like oh I found it I found it it's the
Vistbro it's a little storage table that I got a long while
ago and it fits big plushies really well it looks just like
this And I use it as a storage for my plushies.
It's the K-V-I-S-T-B-R-O.
And it fits plushies.
And I use it as like my table for in front of my couch.
It is literally baby gel, yeah.
Mm-hmm.
Yes.
I got it at Ikea.
But it's quite big.
Hold on.
let me see if I can find like a actually they they advertise
oh wait this one is a little smaller they advertise it as
like using for pillows and blankets and stuff but I put
plushies in there yeah so my fuminto is in jail right next
to my double nimi nightmares she is also in jail for uh for
impersonating a nurse a minto themed version of that table
as merch.
Just put that idea out there.
What even, how do I even make it Minto themed?
But yeah, that's what I use.
Because it's practical and it's storage.
So it's quite nice, to be honest.
If you are really needing some...
Hello?
Come on.
I am a man.
I have long arms.
Need to empty the trash can first.
Oh, everything is glitching out.
Oh, those are under the table.
Put a cafe sign on it.
Or you could get your own and fill it with Minto.
Things.
I don't know.
Oh, baby Jill is still on screen!
Ah, I'm sorry, thank you!
This is how I had an announcement.
With the cancer dinosaur on it!
It's heck by surprise.
Probably had no idea somebody's after her husband.
This is how it happens!
Oh, cutting the lemons.
How did that happen?
Somebody walked over here though.
What happened in here?
The basement.
Jesus, that one was tortured.
Speaking of plushies, my Hikari and Nozomiya Chocopunius
should be coming soon.
Did you ever get the Koharu one?
No, I didn't.
I didn't get the Koharu one because I was moving.
And Ami Ami, like, stopped shipping to the U.S.
for a while.
And I was like, it's fine.
Next time I go to Japan, I'm sure she'll be, like, at some
store.
And I never saw her.
Oh, nice!
I forgot they did that.
Oh, that's not what I meant to do.
There we go.
Yeah, so...
I'm currently...
Koharu-lish.
Thinking of buying a stroller, but the gay baby just does it
all the way useful.
Yeah!
I think it is!
I can't remember.
I did buy some upgrades last time before we ended stream and
I don't remember what I got.
It's okay though.
You also have two maps.
I do?
You're right.
Hello.
Oh my god.
There's like the smallest amount of...
You.
But also, if you're wanting more plushy Minto action,
where would this go?
Up here?
Yeah.
Oh, $100.
And this goes in a questionable place, who knows, at the
moment.
All right.
Washa, washa, washa, washa, washa.
I'm just saying my birthday's coming up.
That's all.
I did say there would be mini merch drop.
Little merch.
Is that it?
Oh.
I thought it was part of the...
Wait.
Is this...
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
Is there $100 behind this, too?
what's here oh my bad there we go
I don't think that's appropriate to do to a painting no no
no no I literally learned I learned from the person that
restored that Jesus picture I learned from the best trust
it's all good
wait is it only two okay it is only two probably could add
some detergent to this but i'm lazy
oh the chairs probably go here
hello lady the
best restoration of all time it's so is literally one of
those situations where it's so bad it circles back to being
amazing so bad it's so good oops oh shoot I forgot so you
get watercolors Neil Breen I still want to watch Neil Breen
with more like people like I feel like Nimi would really
like Neil Breen single mom wine night go up crazy I think I
think the issue is that she's not single.
Oh, see, she's shaking her head.
Not single.
Not wine, mom.
What's this?
I tried to make that call.
But ran out of time.
Oh, no.
Wait.
Her fingerprints are not on the nine, the one, or the one at
all.
Beep, boop.
Okay.
You.
oops
come here ma'am ma'am come here come here come here multiple
gunshot wounds the attacker clearly went off the deep end
did he blame her for her husband's misbehavior what in the
eyeliner is the eyeshadow what is that what what
ma 'am you can afford every makeup artist in the world she's
become the juggler goodness we're missing ah
nice uh is this guy a stealable no what was it g no oh he
goes there my bad oh i'm so sorry I was like stumbling all
over her too.
Still blood on that table.
On this?
Oh, yes, thank you.
I want to see that disappear.
Oh, okay.
I missed like the tiniest.
Teeny time.
Knife my wife!
I can't afford anything.
No, Mr. Yom Yom!
No!
I have one of these mug racks.
I got it after...
I literally got it after Grim Fandango.
And I love it.
It, like, is so...
It enhances my...
My kitchen so much.
Because I have a lot...
I collect a lot of, like, anime dishware stuff.
You know?
And so I want to display it, too.
So, like, it has been so good to display.
play but yeah I literally I saw it in Grim Fandango and I
was like wait I think I want one of those and I was easily
influenced let's see collect evidence which I think is the
body and the move the furniture back to its place what is
not in its place all right come on lady I can't imagine
actually using one of those.
No, but it's so good to display my cute little mugs.
And I have so many.
I recommend, I recommend.
Minto cute.
Oh my gosh, I'm just gonna be like a little interior
designer for you guys.
Gonna be like baby, gay baby jail.
It's so good.
For your plushies.
Oh, Oh yeah, display your mugs.
Is this gonna...
Oh, never mind.
Okay, it's fine.
Uh, what is not in its place?
And we are missing in evidence.
Well, there's still stuff like around here.
What's over here?
Nothing.
Ikea catalog stream one day.
Did you guys see it?
The Ikea!
Xbox collab.
It's actually so cute.
Minky, my brain is over, but I gotta go teach CQC class.
Rest in Glitchways, have fun!
I haven't been able to focus all day.
You got a favorite move I should teach?
Um, the, uh, Purple Nurple.
Yes, there is a collab.
There is an Ikea merch with...
This message didn't age well.
He knows about us.
Stay safe, my team.
dearest i hope to be with you soon in hell um yeah xbox has
been doing so many collabs lately i think like they have a
new ceo or something and she's going nuts though she's like
i was like are we in the era of like xbox everybody's mad at
sony right now are we in the era where xbox starts to starts
to get good but um they outlawed the purple napalm that i
wouldn't uh the the xbox um they have a a tv stand that is
really really cute i already have one so i'm not gonna get
it but tyrant thank you so much for the thank you thank you
thank you the console wars continue oh yeah oh everybody's
better xbox too they fired everyone just kidding want to
enjoy some ice cream with me mint it's homemade cookies and
cream loaded up on oreos i want ice cream i want it yes
please yes please what's this maranashi we can play that
and what's this so much for healthy living what will i do to
improve my life keep a healthy diet i should lose at least
15 pounds to feel good in my own body do home do workouts at
home or in a fitness club at least four times a week less
than a decade back i was a well-known fitness instructor god
damn it i was also miss teen not so long ago right right how
long is not so long ago binto bedroom renovation stream but
she comes to your place and smashes you stop no
they all they have all that wine yet i haven't seen any
cheese yeah she was Cutting lemons.
Focus on the therapy.
It's time to finally heal.
Antidepressants alone won't do it.
Now I know that.
Remember that family time is really important.
I have two great stepkids and an amazing husband.
They give me a lot of strength every day.
I still like to think Helldivers 2 ended the console wars.
What's left is just residual discourse.
Yeah?
Yoink.
Anything else here?
I mean, I don't know.
I think some people will always have things to say.
It's not like they need it anymore.
So true.
People will always have stuff to say.
So you can either just...
Just ignore it.
and do what you like because you like it.
Or you can participate and be unhappy.
That's really all there is to it.
If you enjoy picking fights with strangers on the internet.
Whoa, Aurora Borealis.
Let's see.
Move furniture back.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, this chair wasn't in its right place.
Like, there we go.
There we go.
All right, nice.
And let's see...
Oh, this was the torture scene.
That's right.
Grandpa?
Oh.
Interesting.
Drills.
This was not a drill.
The bloody power drill.
At this time of year, at this time of day, in this part of
the country, localize entirely in my backyard.
Okay.
You're...
This one wasn't enough.
Oh, oh, he's free.
You're free.
He's...
A lot of stab wounds.
Some drill marks.
Easy to see was deeply personal.
So that must be Mark.
Hi, Mark.
Oh, hi, Mark.
38 stab wounds.
38 stab and drill wounds.
I wish I could play Detroit human again.
I mean, I could.
There's different endings.
Bye, Mark.
May I see it?
No.
Where?
Oh, yeah.
Happy birthday.
Use this to take Steiner somewhere nice.
Oh, my God.
Well, unfortunately.
Fortunately for you, he doesn't touch my superchaps.
Ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah.
Oh, don't oh, stay with me, baby.
Setsunang doesn't get a piece of that pie, baby.
Also, it's not my birthday.
In one month.
It's the 1st of October.
You were so close, though.
Tech mogul monthly.
New faces of social media.
Mark Castle.
Use this to take Studdle.
How about I don't take him anywhere?
How about I take my girlies?
We go out to some delicious...
Oops.
Oh, I wouldn't have seen that.
Some delicious Italian food.
Restricted area.
Moving machinery.
What is in here?
I'll take Phoebe and Vicky somewhere instead.
This looks so stealable.
Whoa!
Oh wait, not that...
It was six?
I don't remember.
It was six.
Oh, a key.
To the laundry.
Where...
Have we seen laundry?
Any money in there?
Any money behind here?
Can't believe they're releasing Ace Combat 8 on your
birthday.
I think it's like Two days after my birthday or something,
right?
They literally did it just for me.
Minto punch!
Okay, where's my axe?
What happened in here?
Oh!
I need to be careful Oh!
She doesn't fall.
Oh my god.
It was literally in that area.
it was quite literally that area where I was walking around
and I said oh this area is big but there's not that much to
clean up
oh raiders SJ bond thank you so much for the vibe good day I
don't know I did not see who raided me but thank you these
combat is October 2nd yes yes yes October 2nd we will play
that day it is funny it's right after my birthday though
happy birthday to me
and wink and what's this she deserves a better life Lulu's
suicide oh oh speaking of signer I saw beasties will be
going will be at San Japan I don't know how that's speaking
of Assuming Mitara is still going, that's 5XV Shoujo's.
Could there be an impromptu haunting too?
Nope, I was not invited.
Also, if I were, it would be announced, and if I were, it
also, I wouldn't be able to say it until it were announced.
So yeah, sorry.
Pirate Buck, thank you so much for the 10 gifted!
Phil, thank you so much for the 10 gifted!
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah.
Is that what the weapon was?
Wait, who died here?
Oh, it was that person that fell, huh?
Okay.
Here's Johnny.
Okay, all this here.
Here's...
Every tiny little piece.
Every door.
Okay.
combine combine combine and you that should be all the garbo
I think wait so get rid of trash 86% what am I missing oh
maybe these yeah okay nice did you finish cleaning the
basement no
candy for breaking bones wow that's a nice looking hammer
secret oh oh
it's worth two bucks each these what is this monopoly money.
Ah.
They left a little prison underneath.
Yes.
Totally worth it.
Get rid of the worthless paper from the basement.
Was the achievement I got.
It's not worthless.
Now, come on.
This, though.
What the?
Oh.
Doesn't this look like a door?
To something?
The darkness?
Did someone say the door to darkness?
Monopoly, Super.
Thank you, organizer.
Thank you.
Oh, whoops.
Dang.
Hmm.
Well, we got one secret.
Very nice.
It's 100% a dark soul's fake wall.
That's what I'm saying.
It is, it is, it is.
Is there anything in here?
Oh, I...
to clean it up I think.
Oh I still have to delete the surveillance footage though.
I've not done that yet.
These stinking footprints on them.
They're so hard to clean off.
You gotta walk around every... look at this they do it on
purpose.
They're like I know that it's gonna be hard to get my
footprint off of the carpet.
Back-to-back hits retro rewinds game rental update will be
coming in ball suit.
We'll make sure the mods are updated.
The win is thank you.
I know.
I will need to go back to it once it's updated then for
sure.
Once we get the...
Retro rewind.
I'm such a sucker for these dang simulator games.
They're so satisfying, though, you know?
I see the blood right there.
What's going on in here?
what do
we have here speaking of oh my bad oh my bad is that ninja
what why did why why is everybody dead oh my god have you
seen this man I don't think I have I didn't have good enough
of a gaming chair Who are these people?
Am I supposed to clean this up?
I thought pizza in bed Brother.
Oh, gross.
Disinformer.
Playing games for too long can literally kill you?
No crunch and eternal happiness.
Interview with Exploits Soft CEO.
Everything simulator.
One sim to rule the ball!
That's what I need!
Retro Junk 1777, our first impressions.
Red Mountains, original adventure game review.
I need to play Celestial Empire, baby.
I mean though I have several crime scenes that need
cleaning.
What's your hourly rate?
I go by body.
And that's the only thing I'll accept.
Oh, he's got some tea.
Let's go.
Spicy?
Not mine.
How?
You...
You, why is there milk in a drawer?
You!
Why is there milk in a drawer?
I'm horrified right now.
Does this have blood on it?
It's shelf-sable, yeah?
Actually?
I'm believing you.
I'm gonna leave all my milk in drawers now, then.
I'm trusting you.
Just gotta get started on this.
Room, though.
Whose footprints are these?
Huh?
Oh my gosh, I'm starting to sound like a stupid genome
soldier.
Wait, why actually?
Whose food were these?
Why'd they go over here?
For the pizza?
Oops, that's how I meant to have jokes.
Everything is shelf-stable eventually.
Bob found the milk drawer.
It looks like they were looking for something.
Oh my gosh.
Frizzed up!
Thank you!
What are that?
Pillows?
Very expensive.
The silk kind.
The silk kind that...
Leave your head cool.
Thank you so much for the watch, the sofa!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
There we go.
It won't move like this.
What's wrong?
What are we missing?
I got a new pillow recently.
I need to clear the way first.
What's wrong?
What's in the way?
Does it need the chair?
I got a new pillow recently.
and it's like filled with beans I like it something is
blocking the way toilet paper oh my good no one will even
notice I think they wouldn't have noticed with the toilet
paper I think that would have been normal too oh I think
both of my things are ruined bean pillow yeah the bean
pillow is pretty good sorry I'm all over the place today I'm
like over here let's see good for your neck maybe your
concerns were legit dad had an affair and fucked the whole
family by accident Kara you there yep what's up Mabel I'm
freaking up right now I'm freaking up I'm I think dad is
having an affair.
I overheard him talking to some woman on the phone.
Wasn't mom, I'm sure of that.
Don't go crazy, girl.
It was probably nothing.
I don't know.
Maybe you're right.
IDK, maybe you're right.
Maybe I'm just tripping.
Fo show.
Yeah, we have to do this whole room too.
Oh.
Fo show.
So what, is this the sun then?
Oh, my bad.
Just imagine playing some FPS and ending up with a bull in
your head.
That's what I call immersion.
He wasn't playing an FPS.
Oh my gosh.
This guy, you're not a gamer.
Come on.
Oh, there's a handprint there.
Dang it.
I thought that would work.
Come on.
Come on, man.
Get down there.
Punch.
Ninja!
Oh my gosh.
Okay, watch, we got this.
Yeah!
Okay, perfect.
This is arguably the best song in the game.
Oh, where does this go?
Oh, here.
Milk.
I think this room is clean though.
Seems clean to me.
I know why he needs an office chair.
What is this?
Oh my gosh.
Ducky.
Gamer Ducky.
Alright.
We're gonna rinse this out.
Spent all the money on the gaming setup.
Yeah, most likely.
I think this family doesn't have any issues with that,
though.
Having to worry.
The setup is pretty sick, though.
I'm not gonna lie.
Oh, oh, nice.
Setup is kind of nice.
Tucky, thank you so much, Russell!
You did!
But, okay, let's be...
Only two monitors.
Hmm.
Warning.
Hot.
Do not touch.
If you could possess a person for 24 hours, who would you
possess?
What would you do for the day?
I'd possess...
Sabrina Carpenter.
And I would just walk around and I'd be hot.
I wouldn't have to do anything.
I would just be hot regardless of anything I do.
And I'd be like, Look at how cute I am.
Look at my big booty.
Look at my big boobies.
Look at my fluffy hair.
And I'd be like, La, la, la, la.
And they'd be like, Oh my God, Sabrina, you're so cute.
And I'd be like, Nuh.
Nespresso.
They'd be like, you're so right.
You're so right, bestie.
Live, laugh, love.
Oh my god, wait, it's both.
It's a keep calm and live, laugh, love sign.
Wait, this is...
She hit them all.
She hit everything.
Keeping calm is the best I can do.
Cute Mindo is cute.
Yeah, but like, I could then be...
I don't know, Sabrina Carpenter.
She's got it all.
She's like the full package.
Laughs calmly.
I'm living and I'm laughing.
Actually, I'm not living.
That's maybe my issue.
Maybe my issue is I'm not living.
What's on the computer?
Nothing?
Really?
Are you calm?
No.
I had a crazy dream.
I had a dream last night about something that I'm working on
about my birthday.
And I, it was like one of those types of dreams where it's
like everything goes wrong.
And I was like, oh my god.
I'm already having stress dreams about it.
Hey boys and their eye blew it.
Yeah, exactly, exactly.
I don't know who I possess.
It's not really anybody that I think I'm so curious about.
Wish cleaning stains on a bed were that easy.
It could be.
All you have to do is just mop it.
Don't have a key.
A hatchet will do.
Whoa.
These are really fancy looking all.
It's fine now.
Hold on.
I need a tissue.
Do I have one?
I've snored all over me.
Oh, there's...
I just got you.
I felt it coming.
Okay.
I know that thing would be looking at me in the middle of
the night.
I don't like it.
All right, what else is in here?
Oh, a chair needs to go there.
Oh, this needs to go fixed.
Oh, this needs to be fixed.
I need to clear the way first.
Okay, okay, you're right.
You're right.
This goes somewhere.
Probably here.
No?
Really?
This goes here?
No?
Wait, yes.
I was right.
Yes.
There.
Where does this go?
Oh, here.
Oh, it's dirty.
Oh, y'all.
300 bucks.
These are fine.
It won't move like this.
I'm gonna...
Wish there was an easier way to clean up the carpet, like a
big amount.
Mm-hmm.
Let me...
I'm gonna double check what things...
What skill trees we've unlocked.
Um...
No, pressure washer is still whatever.
We do have the detergent.
Yeah, we can upgrade the sponge after this.
Or rather, like, we can focus.
I mean, we've maxed out the mop, so.
Getting the sponge will be good.
Because this kind of sucks.
Didn't expect the skill.
Oh, the game is so generous.
Yeah!
Nice.
That's what makes these games so good.
fun though is that there's skill trees.
That's why it's like better than normal cleaning.
Look at that.
Move all furniture.
We've missed one.
19 out of... Oh, well, from the first floor.
Who?
The first floor.
Oh wait, no, this is the first floor.
Oh!
Oh, this guy.
There's also...
What's out here?
What's this?
Money.
Can I go out there?
Any secrets?
Oh.
Oopsie.
Now they should be cleaning up their empty bottles is all
I'm saying.
Okay, the only things we have left are...
Oh, deleting the surveillance?
Wait, is there anything over here?
Uh, yes.
Yoink.
They're reading about secrets to success.
They're not so secret if everybody is publishing them,
right?
You put the milk cartons in the trash, too?
like we need to so here we get to delete the surveillance
footage oh yeah our little AI buddy the guy that oh let's
stop here let's do the manual hacking I got this nine two
eight and then oh shoot nice delete delete delete Dilly,
dilly, dilly, dilly, dilly, dilly, dilly.
May I borrow 10 bucks?
Yeah.
There you go.
Oh, we have also the other body that fell to the ground.
Yes, yes.
Then that should be it on this place.
What?
What is playing?
Anything?
Oh, we got this one too.
Oh, we're back in the area where everything is bad for my...
for me.
Laundry room!
That's right!
Thank you!
We got a key for that.
Yes, yes, thank you.
trying to
look at him dang right in the head
maybe here
oh it's a secret nice
oh this is not a laundry room or maybe it is
nice yeah that means this is a free soup but no Yes!
Spinosaurus, don't make me...
Everything that I say sounds bad.
Can't really call it a soft landing.
Hard to imagine losing a child like that.
He's talking about losing children.
Here I am just jamming.
Don't make me tap the sun.
I was gonna say don't make me... ban you?
Which I would not.
I was also gonna say don't make me kill.
you which I wouldn't do that either which
would be worse which would be worse hmm are
both of them dirty
banning is a form of death maybe right this is a paid super
me so you can put the money in my PayPal later for this paid
actor reminder there's no such no such a reminder!
No such... Get out of here.
I told you that I need you to send that on the 21st.
You go against our agreement.
And then you expect me to pay you back?
Alright.
Let's pick up every teeny tiny piece that we have down here.
Surely we'll be able to pick up everything and combine it
into a super bag.
Watch this.
Oh, you'll see.
You'll all see.
Can't pick up anything with a full bag.
Watch this.
Yeah.
I choose death before...
Don't...
Give me...
Wait.
Uh...
Uh, give me death.
Or give me...
Wait, what was it?
What did they say?
Give me liberty?
Give me...
Give me death.
or give me bad that deliberate give me the the well wait I'm
still a little sad he can't pull out both mobs wait there I
was screaming starburst scream give me liberty or give me
death give me minto or give me dust this super may not be
free but it is fun to send at least you admit I think that's
everything
take photos in swimming pool wait what wait I was supposed
to not go back in there what do you mean take photos in
swimming pool ah thank you so much for the 10 gifts okay
Let's see where we're going.
I can't...
I don't know what's happening, but I found this 10 pounds
and it's yours now.
Oh.
No, please!
I'm on a diet!
Please!
Don't give me 10 pounds!
That's like the worst thing you could do!
I have a smaller stature.
10 pounds to some...
I'm stuck in...
internet.
Ten bucks.
This is what is free.
I have freedom from my wallet.
I bet your wallet feels real good right now.
Double in.
Give it to the next guy.
Yeah, yeah.
What are the photos for?
Take photos in basement.
Wait, what am I taking photos for?
What's my city of where did you grow up your accent is hard
to pinpoint i'm ghost grew up in the afterlife
um i hope that helps first floor
ninja i didn't do that i don't know why i'm taking these
photos maybe he wants proof that i did a good job much
helpful Leave the crime scene when you're ready.
Let's go!
Did I get everything?
I guess I did.
No secrets back here, no money.
Doesn't seem like it.
Speaks fluent, spooky.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So I know I just realized you can tell this is a European
game because they called the second floor or the first
floor.
thing wait there's some there's money under my car left by
it wait please no do you think this is a fairy trap or
please please let me grab it it's right there wait wait
it's just a sticker it's literal bait no That was a hundred
bucks!
What do you mean I don't need it?
Yahoo!
Through my boy Benjamin.
Benjamin!
He belongs with me!
My money!
Holy canola!
Perfect.
Let's go.
Echoes of crime.
Oh my gosh.
Third eye.
Here you go.
I picked it up for you, Minto.
You have such talent today.
I missed a secret.
What did I miss?
Was it the $100?
I feel like I would...
Or rather, I thought I was pretty thorough.
Next door.
Dad's taking care of dead bodies.
And you're taking care of dad.
Yeah.
Is this a cat bed?
Why are you staring at the cat bed?
Oh, we took the flamingo!
Cute.
What was I doing?
Go to bed.
Okay.
He's staring at the cat.
Yeah, he's staring at the cat in the cat bed.
I'm trying to...
I think I was seeing if anything changed.
Alright, cool.
Yippee!
Tyler's apartment.
Hey, we're almost done.
Are you ready?
Everybody's cutting lemons.
Not yet.
Kitty!
Have you tried turning it on a...
Yes.
I can try for yourself.
Oh, kitty!
I applied for cat adoption.
God, just shut up.
Try another one.
Oh my god.
I applied for kitty for adoption.
They asked me a million questions.
What is going on?
Oh my god.
Oh my gosh.
Oh look at that.
at us we're building furniture shelf
do they want to do home inspection too i'm i'm not sure they
they i'm still in talks i saw that febe is coming to kamori
con here in portland oregon hoping to see you here someday
too that'd be fun i've never been yeah everyone's cutting
lemons and drinking deer then dying never do those things
you guys look at our room it looks so besides that it looks
so nice who's a good boy who's not working for a mom is
adoption like fostering a permanent living kitty it's a
permanent living kitty fostering would be you know i was oh
my gosh i'm so i'm so i'm so wired to check the drawers and
steal the money i tried to do it to my own room But yeah, I
don't think I could ever be a foster parent because I would
just grow attached to Kitty.
Wait, why are we doing this to her room?
Oh,
I'm so poor.
I can't even afford living cookies.
I have to buy ghost cookies.
Our place is looking so nice though.
Wait.
Dexter!
Yes!
This time I have an easy peasy job.
Easy peasy!
You need to clean up the dead red, Tyler.
One small apartment, just a few parties.
Oh, goody holographic food again.
And that's it.
That fool and his normal girlfriend hosted a conspiracy
meeting against me.
Now at least I'm done for good with this normal shit.
For fuck's sake, Tyler.
You of all people should have known that this guy wouldn't
let it pass.
You're like ghost cookies would actually be quite pricey.
Is Tyler dead?
Oh my god, we actually have food in our fridge and stuff now
too
creepy mannequin Tyler the businessman
what's up mr.
Kovalski you see lately I've been thinking a lot about the
future that's kind of crazy because it all started getting
better ever since you saved my ass from that rob rob
situation people in the gang you really respect me now and I
feel as if my whole life made a quick 180 I have a lot I
have lots and lots of plans I even think of creating my own
in the future.
Find yourself some free time and I will tell you the details
in person.
Jim might be a little crazy, but he's damn good to his loyal
people, and I'm the most loyal.
The best gangster ever.
He also speaks highly of you, so I guess we might be kind of
on the same page, haha.
But just in case, let me know if there's anything I can do
to help you.
He's super dead.
Tyler!
Tyler, what did you do?
He's gangster.
He's super dead.
It turns out that some nomad leftovers tried to make their
last will to get their revenge against me.
Pathetic bastards.
Anyway, I got them first.
As I always do.
That stupid rat Tyler was trying to impress some ex-nomad
bitch and sold me out.
He even invited these guys over for a secret meeting in
order to join their scheme and screw me.
Once I found out, I sent my people to spoil their fun.
they're finally done for good Jim is this like the place
right next to me because didn't he say he was like moving in
next door
you ever get the idea that Jim might be a touch paranoid
maybe oh close close close goodbye no more emails from Tyler
I guess
think big Jim's gonna get what's coming to him and it's
gonna be by my hands sometimes I wonder if it all had to end
up like this Tyler was a grown man his own decision the
upgrades it's okay we can still do them do to save him but
was that death truly necessary don't say that wait why at
last here I am.
Tyler.
Oh.
Oh, we sound kind of sad about it, though.
He had a kitty!
Oh, yeah, that's right.
He had the two cats.
We saw that.
Oh, yeah.
Big Jim's always listening.
You're right.
Let's see.
Can't switch skills.
The only thing is you can't switch skills during the
mission, but we can still purchase them, so
let's do do the increase strength for and increase stats
apply those.
What else did we have?
Increased duration.
Oh, the weakening speed.
We got to do that too.
We got to do that.
I'm even going to get this and this.
Six sense.
Cleaner sense also highlights pieces of missing furniture.
You can use cleaner sense without limits.
Hmm.
No, we don't have to restart.
We'll be a Aoki.
Garbage can.
Garbage detection range.
Oh, it's one or the other.
That's right.
What is the...
I just did the...
I did the weakening speed.
So we did...
upgrade him as much as we can you can use two sponges at the
same time as the final one for the sponge maybe we should
have aimed for that we'll do we'll do this and this and then
next time we'll be able to get this final one it's four
points but now I have zero points so we will do a wheel dual
wield our sponges
Artiste, an artist.
Please don't touch anything.
I'm tired of constantly changing strings and we need to
save.
Love you.
Trisha.
Tyler seems to have liked music.
But I guess music didn't like him back.
Oh, wow, yeah.
The kitty even made it here.
Oh yeah, she's shredding.
You got this, Trisha.
You got this.
Well, actually...
Let's see, where can I put my...
Here we go.
Is that him?
Wait.
Are you...
I don't know who anybody is.
Yeah, maybe not.
Maybe not.
You had it at the time.
Oh, the kitty came over here.
That's so sad.
I don't want to think about that.
Let's start by getting, like, some of these bullets.
Some of these bullets.
I just unloaded on the guy.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
The kitties are...
They might have escaped.
They might have seen the situation and...
Oh!
Two lines.
They got COVID.
We didn't even say anything about it.
It was just dot, dot, dot.
I can't help but envision your call to arms against Big Jim
as what?
As a rousing Lord of the Rings scene.
You have my sword.
You have my bow.
And my mop.
There's one thing Big Jim.
can't beat me in and that is that is the cleanliness of a
location I'm the best janitor there is I'm the best janitor
there is I hope this isn't him let's put on some music we
got a new one actually this one oh this is by Trisha
sorry Tyler, this isn't the kind of trouble I can get you
out of.
Oh, it's so sad.
Who knows?
If I won't end up like that one day.
The music is so fitting.
I can't believe they had a medical test to determine if you
heard missing Santa babies.
Yeah.
because many people were disgusted they were disgusted and
had to get medical attention afterwards you know why is this
song like there's something like you know MGS4 about it
Metal Gear Gearsolive 4 has been like, I mean, Metal Gear
already took over my timeline a lot, but it's been
especially taking over my timeline because of, like,
everybody playing Master Collection and stuff.
So that's pretty fun.
Dear Mr. Novak, regarding your recent application, we just
found a perfect flat for you and your lovely girlfriend.
It has a big kitchen, one bathroom, two bedrooms, and a
balcony and is located in a quiet residential area with good
transport links and shops all around.
I will be glad to give you a tour before the possible
signing of a real estate purchase agreement.
It's all within the discussed budget.
We really were trying to get your shit together, weren't
you, Tyler?
A lot of people playing it for the first time.
Yeah, it's so fun.
So fun to see.
Well, this one makes me so sad, though.
This one is sad.
If you were a loved one, we're impregnated, or born from
Santa, baby, you do for compensation.
I guess we knew Tyler might have it coming, though.
Wait, what is this?
Oh, what?
Did they have, like, a projector or something?
Kitty getting their paws everywhere.
This one is dark.
This place is dirty, dirty, dirty.
Ugh.
People, people.
Me to all the new MGS players.
This is good, isn't it?
I know.
Oh, yeah, they escaped.
Both the kitties escaped.
Oh, okay, we're back to happy music now.
We're back to just cleaning up in a parvo.
Oh, whoops, wrong thing.
There was something else I needed to punch, no?
Maybe I'm crazy.
Chips.
Yeah, the kitty has escaped.
All is well.
My bud, whoever that was.
I really need you to move, actually.
You have some trash underneath you that I'd like to grab.
My psychic vision tells me.
Who are you?
It's time to leave.
The movie night is over.
There it goes.
What is this?
A.
And how about you, dude?
IDK, I'm kind of working out my life right now.
What do you mean?
I found a new job, normal job.
Time to move on.
You?
Normal job?
Yeah, right.
It looks like they were trying to get their lives together.
This map really is a big bummer.
Not design-wise, just emotionally.
Right?
They were just trying to be...
They were just...
They were trying to get their lives together.
So it's sad.
They were like, we give up the life of crime with
my silly music.
Oh my gosh, there's so much on the floor.
Everything's like a teeny tiny piece, too, you know.
It is a common theme in shows.
Golden era of Sudoku.
Extreme difficulty.
Be careful.
Are these trashed too?
No.
Rubber Ducky?
Oh my gosh, there's so much garbage.
Okay, we're at 82% though.
We're almost there.
We're almost there, everybody.
I've never been told to be careful of P. Cross.
So, I don't know.
Sudoku players, they're probably they're playing a dangerous
game.
a dangerous game.
Oh my god, there's so many.
Okay, but also how many people were here?
I don't want to know how much this place costs.
In the city?
Probably so much.
They spared no bullets.
They really didn't, huh?
Oh, right here.
Two more little bullets.
Yeah!
Now as long as I don't make a mess, as long as I make no
mistakes...
Wait, what did I use?
The strength.
Yes, and clean.
Yes.
Alright.
We're all sudsed up.
Does the kiddies even have an allowance?
it's too dangerous
Tyler I invited my pals there will be five of us I'm not so
sure about them won't they try to pull some some stuff come
on these are my friends I know sweetie it's just no you no
yeah you're right it'll be fine I think you're gonna
actually like them just try to get along all right Okay,
it'll be fine.
It did not go fine.
It was not fine.
Yeah, it was not fine.
My game really is bugging out today.
I don't know why.
Yeah.
Get that body clean.
You know it.
Oh my gosh, I'm scared.
It's fine.
No messes.
We're fine.
Everything's fine.
Oh my god!
No!
I didn't think it was dirty already.
Gosh.
Why are people's blood so thick?
My mop gets dirty so fast!
We'd be juicy.
Juicy.
okay i feel like that's clean but it says it doesn't want to
be because it's thicker than water blood is thicker than
water tastier too all right all right nice clean up some
tough stains here do you guys think you have like a sweet
blood You know, I think mosquitoes like ectoplasm Because I
always am getting mosquito bites Always getting mosquito
bites Oh my gosh I went outside yesterday And I was like
There was a A local park I wanted to go see By my new maid
cafe I hadn't had time before So I made time yesterday And I
saw This is a park I'm used to this Otters!
They were so cute!
In my park!
Oh my god, they really do not good therapy for me.
Okay, I don't think she likes the Sudoku actually.
Amateurs, okay.
Yeah.
It was so nice.
I was like, dang.
Maybe...
Hunting of Sudoku therapy.
Made cafe.
Being a, hunting a made cafe for so long.
I'm solving Sudoku.
I wouldn't be able to see that.
I'm kind of starting to get how it works.
My therapist told me that it's good for my mind.
But shit is hard.
Like, good number.
Am I supposed to type in here?
God, you better be right, Doc.
Because I am freaking stretching my mind here.
But I think I actually...
I actually feel slightly better.
Sudoku?
Maybe you should have thought about getting a second opinion
on that.
Yeah, because my man's playing Sudoku.
What a dummy.
You should be playing Sudoku.
Sudoku therapy, guys.
Not even once.
Oh!
Wait.
This one's not completely dirty yet.
Now it's completely dirty.
Sudoku.
More like Suduki.
Ah, got him, got him.
Sudoku is not my kind of relaxation.
I don't know.
Some people, like, really like numbers legitimately.
And they're like, yeah, numbers make me feel good.
Me?
Numbers, like, they skip.
me as a ghost is scared I am scared of the numbers you know
or like how people are scared of ghosts that's what I meant
to say what do they mean that's what I'm talking about it's
a mystery and it scares me what's scarier to you spiders are
numbers maybe spiders oh yeah the best song is back baby
mopping the bed i'm mopping the bed
turn it up
Oh, it just makes me want to mop!
Arithmetic relaxes me.
Even distracts me from migraine.
Really?
I hallucinate spiders in the morning.
I don't have to hallucinate.
I just have spiders.
Silly doctor using that old school Sudoku therapy.
Yeah, meow tower therapy!
Yay!
Meow Tower Therapy!
Everybody play...
Everybody play Peacross Meow Tower!
What's... what's in the way?
Oh, like the tiniest bit of...
Oh, there we go.
Okay.
Like no one was ever here.
Yep.
Uh-huh.
What is this song?
It's fine.
I don't really care about it.
let's do out of the hood
check their drawers for money and things batteries wait it's
missing a drawer should I be putting that bag oh my gosh the
cat even walked the cats walked everywhere
playing Sudoku while watching the No way!
Oh.
Oh, my bad.
We'll grab that in a second.
Okay, do this.
Grab you.
And put it back.
Oh, a little chair there.
Okay.
Oh, there's more blood on here.
Oh my gosh, it's so hard to see.
I would have never seen it.
This is like the worst carpet to have for Bloodstains.
Or maybe the best.
Nobody would see it.
No one would even know it's there.
Bill, thank you!
Is there a YouTube Sudoku's playable?
Oh my gosh, I'm at.
Probably, right?
There must be.
Probably, I think.
There's a YouTube playable.
for everything.
Playables, if they were good, I'll be honest, ever since
that YouTube playable stream that I did, long, long time
ago, sometimes I'll still play the games.
Sometimes I go back and I'm like, yeah, I'm still gonna play
this game.
Something is blocking the way.
Oh, like all the stuff that's blocking the way?
Got it.
I got this one.
Alright, we can do that.
back where it blocks the family sim no nothing like that but
there are some games that i like do play oh my gosh i'm
scared there we go
like if i'm like if i have like i don't know 10 minutes to
to kill before like a meeting or something like that i'll
just i'll just put it on i'll just put on like a dumb
youtube playable game they're not bad to kill a couple
minutes.
That's what I mean!
That's what I'm saying!
Oh, sorry.
What'd you say?
Is this clean?
It is now.
Okay, good.
They're both clean.
Where does this go?
Probably in here, right?
No?
I guess not.
No, it's not clean.
So Dokku on YouTube labels would somehow need to include
basketball as an ultimate courtship ritual.
yeah you're already on youtube so it's super convenient i
know right i feel like i played myself by like like trying
them out and then being like i was like yeah these these are
gonna suck these are gonna these are gonna be so bad but the
thing is is like they're what it reminds me of is like those
terrible ad games that you see like like if you're like
having to watch an ad to uh oh I forgot about my AI guy oops
that's wrong I forgot about him because he's like in here um
what were they saying but yeah they remind me of those bad
ads but like you actually don't have to pay for the uh for
anything in them like they're actually totally free so I
feel like and I don't have to download anything So I can
just get all like the stupid like five seconds of Dopamine
that I want from it and then I'm done Oh, the slop is fine
as a treat There's a kawaii Japanese setting for the art
filter.
We do know this I like this one the most though.
Hello We'll do the cute anime girl for now
I feel like I got an instant again Why am I so...
I'm doing my part.
Hi.
Oh, there's a third monitor!
I told you guys!
The third monitor!
Where would this
go?
Can I steal the...
Oh, wait, what's this behind them?
Can I steal the astronaut?
What is this?
What is it?
Look at a bright light!
It's dark in here!
Oh, here's the other one.
Uh, here.
Okay.
It's sugar.
Suck.
No, it wasn't!
Wait, there was a cocaine?
Wait, really?
Was it actually?
Oh, here.
That's what the kids call sugar.
Oh, they're supposed to be this guy here.
It was a weed.
Oh!
Why didn't you say so?
I'm stealing even from my friend.
Oh, then I gotta blow my nose.
Oh,
there's the other...
Wait, this looks dirty still.
Okay.
There we go.
Just get our monitor all full of...
All full of water.
This went here.
Oh, that's why.
There we go.
Okay, I have to get all this blood anyway, though.
Oh, my goodness.
Okay, let's start.
We'll clean it up.
Okay, that was fast.
Alright.
You like the rock of BGM?
Yeah, let's start cleaning up these people.
This place is finally starting to look a little cleaner.
Sometimes you come into these places and you're like, oh my
gosh, it's so overwhelmingly, like, dirty.
Little by little though.
Sorry, I didn't mean to hit you, Tricia.
Sorry, Tricia, I didn't mean to punch you!
What does the robot box do?
It apparently makes the stains easier to clean.
Yoink.
Stealing from my friend Tyler.
All right.
Oh, pizza!
at least they the oven's off right garbage
and maybe more money really questioning sometimes what are
in these drawers you know there's the sugar sometimes you
can find $300 so it's worth the pizza in this game seems
quite curse no like anytime someone's eating pizza they die
there's always there's been pizza in like nearly every dead
person's house i think of this game guys maybe pizza can't
pizza friday is cancelled this week maybe maybe we gotta be
a little careful you won't stop me
It's like girl's band cry.
The pudding that makes you cry.
Instead, in this situation, it's the pizza that kills you.
Oh my.
Is this the creepy song?
I think so.
How does it get all over the ceiling?
I guess using the pressure washer would be nice to like...
Day one day blinding pizza
If pizza kills you then I don't want to live You're a
funeral Literally Hope you enjoy that slice
Does this go somewhere?
Aha Oh And you Yeah It'd be so worth...
You know what?
I mean, I'm already dead, so I can't really say too much,
but...
I would also die again for pizza.
Oh, what's this?
Looks like normal party supplies.
Beer Infinity!
Hummus?
For Carla.
We got ice cream, we got waffles!
I think I might be in charge of ordering lunch at work this
Friday.
Better make it tacos!
Beer infinity.
Oh, holy water!
The end.
I fought that guy.
Metal Gear.
Everything's a Metal Gear reference.
Are there any secrets in this game?
Holy water.
Yoink, some cash.
Oh, kitty litter.
Mio hon tuske.
Oh,
this one is...
Okay.
Maybe the other side?
Yeah, there we go.
Okay.
Let's see.
Yoink.
Oh, there's still a...
Oh, this is still right here.
Okay.
A little bit more blood here.
Oh, already?
Oh, my gosh.
Oh.
Holy water.
You.
I'm right here.
Little buddy.
You know, we're in the beer months, Minto.
September beer?
October?
November?
December?
July!
We got all the blood!
Where is it?
Oh, what's this?
Blink.
Oh!
That was supposed to go here, actually.
July is a funny way to spell beer.
Fourth of beer.
Oh, this guy fell over, that's why.
You were sad.
Real again.
Sorry, Paul.
This was out of my control.
Paul and Tyler.
I hope at least you're reunited with your son now.
Oh my god, that's so sad!
Wait.
I'm legitimately confused what is what furniture I haven't
moved back.
Oh my god.
And then we're missing a cushion.
I can't find it at all.
The office chair.
This guy?
In the hallway.
Cushion is on the cat tower.
What is it?
Ah, thank you.
Okay, so just two more.
Oh, that one was sneaky.
Is there any secrets here?
It's like a tower of boxes.
Just a box, they always say.
Just a box.
I think I just made it harder for myself though.
The kitty fort had to be done.
I'm sorry.
Gamers never look up?
Wait, what's up?
Money.
Ah, here.
Alright, that's one thing.
Oh.
And there's another thing.
And there's a thing to steal.
For some reason, I thought the stuff would, like, show up.
the walls but it did not I love the potato chips in this
really fancy like mega fancy shelving there are a couple of
secrets secrets aware can
I have a hint cupboard this one
washing machine Are you just saying things now?
You just saying things now?
Thank you!
That's actually a hint.
That was a good hint.
Defending sucks.
so sus let's see what was the next one calculator
oh my god oh here's some wait this is yeah that's a that's a
money i don't think we've heard this song before
watch this
Um...
Close enough.
Yeah!
I didn't miss nothing.
Wait, is there, are there other secrets?
Sometimes they're hard because like, I like the ones that
are full rooms, you know what I mean?
Sometimes they're like, like that one.
This one was kind of clever.
Sometimes they're tough though, right?
I think if you tab, it shows if you've missed.
No, tab is to bring up my stuff.
Maybe here?
Oh, I don't have any points to buy this time.
It's in the main room.
A French baguette.
Oh, boy.
Oh, no.
I've missed a number of secrets so far.
They can be, I mean, they're secrets, so...
You know, you find some, you miss some.
Oh my god, shut up.
Yeah, I thought...
Is there a suspicious brick?
Out of place?
Here's a secret, you're the best if you don't.
And all of us are preaching very much, sinister, thank you!
I won't, I won't.
That one's a scary one.
Norris!
Thank you!
Welcome!
Jesse!
Thank you so much for the fun!
Good day!
But the senpai.
The cupboard's under the shelves.
I was looking there too.
Oh, wait.
Secret is covered.
What?
Oh.
I'm taking this home.
Self-inflicted wound.
Renewed every day.
What?
Yay, thank you guys.
Oh, I thought...
Okay.
Aha.
Hopefully that's all of them.
Yahoo!
Then we can leave.
Covered hit was real, too.
I was just thinking of the different covers.
All right.
We're good.
Perfect.
Yeah.
It's so hard not wanting to 100% the rooms in this game.
You know what I mean?
Because like it's just so satisfying to do it and it's not
really even like that tedious you know like if it was like
really annoying about it then obviously clean getting 100%
anything is going to be annoying but...
Yippee!
Yeah, it is therapeutic, right?
I love this game.
I'm home, Dexter.
Where's my favorite puppy?
Where's my puppy?
Why are we packing up my daughter's room?
Where's my dog?
Where's my dog at?
Oh, the cookies are still...
I still have my favorite quantum cookies.
Where's my dog?
Oh, Dexto.
Times are changing, but you're still such a good boy.
Oh, yes.
Yes, I agree.
All right, we're good.
Yes, yes, who's calling me?
Outstanding job, Kavarski.
This mad Tyler tried to get to me, and I can smell trains
for miles.
Good thing you, Mr. Kavarski.
I'm not like them.
Nope.
more unhinged with each day i just really hope he doesn't
get any wrong ideas so i won't be next on his list right how
how are you just like how would you know you took the sudoku
golden era we took that like how would you know that one day
he doesn't be like actually you're against me too and then
then gets then you're on the hit list Oh.
Oh, yeah, we don't need TV.
Oh, that was pretty good.
Be your old clock.
Yes?
It's Jim.
My daughter got herself in a little bit of trouble.
Your daughter.
She will contact you soon and I need you to help her.
Do well and obviously you'll get paid like always.
you know every secret secret about all the bad stuff he's
done so it makes sense he would want to clean that clean up
that loose end at some point right exactly wait that's such
a good point yeah like you know everything about him
upgrades yeah we'll get some upgrades we'll get some
upgrades oh yes we were gonna do the dual wielding oh yeah i
also want to do an additional mob?
What's this last one?
They can no longer leave stains.
Wait.
Um, I don't think that not leaving stains is such a huge
deal, because I feel like I'm pretty good about that.
We could also do the improved bucket.
Oh, it slows down the rate which your tools get stained.
We'll do these two.
Okay.
We'll do those two.
Yeah, I think it's a waste of points, especially for, like,
a later...
A later addition.
We can do those detergent that increases the washing
surface.
Increases quantity of detergents.
We'll do this and this one.
We'll go more in on the detergents.
And then we can do the improvements.
with bucket and stuff next time i think i also do want to
like increase duration stuff i think that's pretty nice also
where's my dog where's my dog oh what are you doing in here
what's up dexter let me guess your tail fully loaded buckets
with like three types of detergents are so good yeah pet
dexter 15 times wait why are we getting rid of everything
though I
haven't I can't I haven't gotten any like letters from my Oh
wait we can check our email Wait what's out here Whoa Wow
we've had this this whole time Okay A little oasis here
We're renovating this Welcome to membership thank you so
much Thank you thank you Freaky mannequin replacing my wife
Alina!
Hi, Dad.
Lately, I've been feeling a bit worse.
It's frustrating how weak my body feels sometimes, and I
have to stay in bed all day.
I need to rest more to get back on track, but the doctors
say it might take some time.
I miss you a lot and really wish I could come home to bed
with you.
I know I need to recover first, though, because they won't
let me leave otherwise.
But I'm strong!
Just wait for me a little longer.
I can't leave Dexter hanging.
Love you.
me my daughter my daughter
hi I am Amber big Jim's daughter I need your help Mr.
Kovalski so there was this party in my place and we had some
brand new cool drugs to make things fun but lol there was
some dope that was some dope shit and everyone kind of went
crazy somehow I fell asleep then just kind of woke up and
everyone was dead So like, whatever, will you help me out?
Daddy said you probably should, but no pressure.
It's a summer resort my daddy gave me, and I don't want any
trouble, you know?
By the way, dead bodies smell really, really bad.
Do what you have to do.
Burn them, dismember, dissolve in a barrel, throw in a
river.
I don't care.
Just make sure nobody finds out.
XO, XO, I'm bar.
No.
This might be our biggest location yet.
family of psychos I know for real she's like oh yeah
dismember the bodies do what you gotta do whatever we've
moved our man cave and the heater and everything the
differences in that like around the house can be pretty
subtle I like it you know hi I'm like a farrake girl and
someone issuing amber alert
the hit better amber who would have thought like father like
daughter this whole party didn't even really seem necessary
who is going to move to a place called loud valley
mountain team look at the bamboo ship 11 and do them to your
cat step on your keyboard.
Let's get this party started.
Oh.
Wait, there's already blood over here?
Extroverts move to Loud Valley.
Why is there blood right here?
How are we already at blood?
Do you think they get noise complaints?
Probably for being too quiet.
They're like, we can't hear you partying!
This is a bucket
oh my god they shaved her they shaved her they were jealous
of her
hair holy moly what were they cooking people wait it
actually seems like maybe like a barrel exploded or
something I think actually
A crossbow!
You should leave hiding the evidence to trained
professionals.
Like me.
I'm a well-trained professional.
Ew.
No looking at ducks.
This goes against my religion.
What do you mean I can't look at the ducks?
That's what I say to you.
Maybe they're like men.
Mega cursed or something.
Can you guys hear the music?
Sounds like strong bad music.
What
am I stealing?
What is this?
I'm stealing meat patties or something.
What is that?
The system is down.
Where's it coming?
That was from the crossbowl?
Oh,
here it is.
I found it.
Adarack.
Yo, snag your drip, because Adarack's about to yeet us on a
cosmic riz.
Get lit!
the stars sheesh
how did this guy even die in bed with a with a what is this
demon yeah
i don't know what that means either party like there's no
tomorrow beer wait am i gonna lag again we're okay
Oh, oh,
oh, this place is humongous.
No running.
This place is humongous.
What
was that?
Spooky sound.
Oh, whoops.
I'm pressing the wrong thing.
Good old heal.
Alrighty.
Whoa.
Okay.
I'm just exploring.
I'm just getting a feel for the place first of all.
There is a water thing in here, though.
Were they really working here?
What happened?
Guys, we're so drunk right now.
Perfect time for a podcast.
So freaking, freaking, freaking drunk.
Furgly.
Women and Doki Sabiro clock.
I don't think they had to survive.
Tommy, Tommy, what happened?
I'm coming for you.
Sounds of a man falling on the ladder.
Never in a million years.
I would have guessed what happened here.
Me?
Neither.
Oh my god.
There's so much blood.
for somebody who just only fell on a...
All right, we'll start in here.
This is like a kind of isolated area, you know, so maybe
it's a good place to...
What's that?
What is it?
Oh, yeah, baby.
That's a one way to get through the job.
We'll start in here so that we can just kind of...
I don't know.
There was an upstairs even, so...
Snake was here too.
So this guy, yeah, just fell?
I don't think that...
If so many people died at, like, parties like this...
I don't think people would keep having them, you know what I
mean?
A lot of people are not.
Oh, yeah!
Oh, my God.
Look at this guy!
Oops, sorry.
You should make...
alcohol with ladders it's not the rarest thing i guess i got
him oops i keep punching him instead throw nice one how do
we get up there like this and
then throw away outside
with what i've seen is wild it doesn't happen more often
really well i mean it's kind of like how when there's like a
car accident or something the oh here we go the sober people
tend to die because the alcohol makes it loosey-goosey so
the people that are drinking tend to and here i thought i've
already seen everything i forgot to clean this but yeah they
tend to be the ones that live
yeah they don't tense up yeah yeah
Understood, boss.
Now I'll always drink before driving.
When did I say that?
You just wanted an excuse!
Don't blame your debauchery on me!
What the hell happened here, though?
Why is this guy pink?
It's pink.
are you an angel because you fell from heaven what what are
we talking about mr.
Kovalski oh sorry oh my god that's my best throw yet oh I
keep punching them ladies literally falling for him awesome
all right there we go let's clean up this room
We'll save all the detergent for some of those bigger rooms
and everything, because otherwise we will run out,
unfortunately.
These guys didn't even fall, though, so I don't understand
why he's making falling puns.
You know?
It doesn't quite make sense.
Oh, there's some cash there.
Explosion sent the bald lady flying in him.
Oh, you think so.
That would make sense, huh?
Oh yeah.
Look at me go.
I'm a machine.
Oh my god, I cannot be stopped.
Look at me go.
Look at this.
Holy cow, there's so much.
You know what?
This is a perfect spot for the pressure washer.
that I have not upgraded at all.
When in doubt, use all of your items so you don't have to go
back downstairs as often.
Oh yeah, my little robot helper!
Yeah.
What was that?
Oh, come on.
We were so close.
The greatness.
Honestly though that did a really good job.
That did a really good job.
Good job buddy.
Alright let's clean this up.
I'm a machine.
Look at me go.
Is that everything up here?
Who knows scrubbing could be this exhilarating?
I always knew.
And the pancake.
What a shame.
Side of the window.
I got it, no?
Okay, and you.
Nice.
Hmm.
Oh, wait.
Actually, we can just take this back now.
I'll double check, but...
I'm pretty sure I got everything up there.
Yeah, see?
I got it.
We're good.
Pretty sure this room is fine.
Unless there's secrets in here or something, but...
I would not know.
I would not know!
We'll come back if we want to.
Should look from where she went in from.
She?
As in me?
Am I the she?
Wait.
Are we- wait.
What tense are we referring-
You got this.
What are you a stand-up comedian?
Get in there.
That's me.
All this trash.
Oh my goodness.
With the lighters, we don't want to pick those up.
There's a little bit of blood here we can take it.
Or actually, it's going to be quite a bit, isn't it?
Because it's like this.
We have to clean up the ash too.
The blood and the ash.
The world will turn to ash.
My favorite quote ever.
I need to clear the way first.
Oh, you're right.
Oh, this is a toughy spot.
There's some evidence under there, though.
I want to see.
Legendary quote.
Mr. Kovalsky cleaned the scene of my death?
I don't think it...
I hope it's not this violent.
You know, though, where you, like... Have you ever heard
that That, like, that saying that, like, if you have moles,
that's where you died in a previous life.
You know, like, I have some moles in places that I'm like, I
believe this could be it, you know?
Oh, shoot.
We're not doing such a great job.
You know what?
You died in your backyard?
That's where you have a mo...
Oh,
wait.
How's that possible?
That's not on your body.
You've got a mool on your arm.
Me too.
Okay, we're missing.
Oh, still?
Oh yeah, it's pretty dirty actually.
Nice.
What about moles on your butt?
That's what I've always wondered.
I mean, did I literally get stabbed in the butt?
It could be.
What if I was running away and someone shot me with an arrow
on my butt?
It could be.
I think.
And I was like, ah!
My butt's so big!
And I took that hit!
Oh, you wink.
I couldn't be a voice.
because I just got such a big butt.
Whose phone is this?
Girls, he's acting weird.
What is he planning?
Sweetie, I have an idea.
We can all write our thoughts at the same time.
One, two, three.
He's seeing someone else?
Unsent message.
Oh my god, there's groups chat is called the baddies yeah
the butt hitbox is 200% bigger I can't help it
naruhodo hmm time for a bag swap was he seeing someone else
that dog guys don't cheat it sucks nobody like oh my god
there's somebody here too oh oh Oh my god, he's family guy
death posed.
He's family guy death posed.
No littering.
Oh, we'll be able to go in there sometime, I believe.
That must have been some huge blast.
Yeah, killed like everybody.
Only cheat.
in casinos so true oh oh oh that's right forgot about you
guys my bed
holy cow outdoors we're oh there's a lot going on huh oh my
gosh can we not do this thank you i'm glad i can pop don't
talk to the dogs Why?
Why can't I talk to them too?
Hmm.
Ducks lie.
What does this one say?
Oh, no fire.
Wait.
Then why would you have a fire pit?
This place is whack.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, sorry again.
What?
Look at...
Oh my gosh.
There we go.
Oh, holy cow.
Oh, hamprint.
From who?
First try.
I always get it first try.
Every time.
What's back here?
Yeah, I was gonna say, I think I can axe this.
Did I find a secret?
Secret!
And lots of traps.
Should have stuck to a good proven stuff.
What's that mean?
Wow.
Got a nice little hideaway thing in here.
I'll take all of that.
Thank you very much.
I'm the cleaner.
okay so we can't go in there yet let's get rid of this
person the baddies
oh death gonna propose to you oh so this girl thought he was
gonna propose the one girl thought he was gonna that he was
cheating on her to a crisp she must have been caught in an
explosion from the campfire wait do you think she lost
explosion?
That's intense.
The explosion is the explosion that makes you bald.
Wait, I think this guy over here is bald too.
I thought she was just a baddie.
What's this?
Come on, it's already filming.
Fuck the steering wheel.
Come on.
Don't try this at home, kids.
Yeah, this guy went bald too from it.
Driving under the influence cleans up.
Wait, maybe he was already bald.
He wasn't burned up.
I can't tell.
Who's trying to be purposefully bald in this game?
Let's clean all this up.
No, no, no, no.
Everybody's bald in the afterlife.
That's not true.
What do you think I am.
You think I'm bald?
You calling me bald?
You calling me a baldie?
Whatever happened to that guy.
Guys, remember Baldie's Basics?
That was like one of the...
You know what?
We never got like Baldie Basics clones.
At least not that I know of.
I feel like every popular like big Indie horror game.
Got at least some sort of like super...
Like got crazy knockoffs.
But I don't remember all these basics doing.
Ever having like a super surge.
You know what I mean?
Any of these stealable?
Oh, come on.
Baldi cannot be replicated.
I guess not, huh?
They cracked the code.
Why is there no cash in here?
Oh, what's this?
Over again.
Hmm.
Here's a tip.
You can actually get infinite detergents by using two
buckets.
Clean the mop with one and add the detergent with the other.
Oh!
I think I get it!
I mean, it's a little inconvenient because you'd have...
to run back and forth but wait that's huge that's super
brain wow oh my gosh give me the money
that's really a big brain
can i get over there by being ultra creep huh yes i can
Yes.
Hardcore.
Who knew this too was Minecraft?
I thought this would be a secret in here.
I wish there was a place to put buckets though.
Eh.
Okay.
Unfortunately, our own- we have- wait, hold on.
One bucket place here.
One over in here.
I don't think there's anything else closer to do the double
bucket trick.
Hmm.
Oh my god!
The explosion that makes you bald claims another!
Another one.
They must have blown all over.
Yeah.
Why did all the girls get blown up?
Baldi actually got a finished game.
It's called Baldi's Basic Plus.
It's a roguelike.
With tons of levels and items and characters.
How many people know about it because it fell into
obscurity?
Wait, was the game originally not finished?
You're teaching me two things, Fiznum.
I didn't know that the original wasn't even done.
they put propane in the fire pit there's no fire pit in here
I think unless it like flew through the window I guess it is
the glass from like a window breaking or something
originally it was a game jam game oh that makes much more
sense I see I see
um I think
I still think it's just surprising that like Baldi's felt
like one of those like you know 2020 games that people
really started to obsess over but it didn't get like a ton
of oops oh they're both dirty that's why it didn't get a ton
of uh
clones is all Yeah, it was pretty short-lived, right?
Hmm.
Oh, well.
I mean, that's pretty cool, too, that it didn't get a bunch
of clones.
Not saying it's a bad thing.
Maybe we can move the bucket and use one sink for both.
Yes.
Let's do that.
This is obviously the cleaning bucket.
Okay.
Right, we'll keep the cleaning bucket here.
You're so right.
And then the other one.
Yeah.
Yes.
Oh, now we have...
Wait.
Resistance?
Also, while we do that, we'll grab the Ozonator and put him
in here.
Oh.
Why'd you say that?
It's not even that big of a room, but it's fine.
Um, whatever makes it faster, right?
Let's do the, uh, the strength detergent.
And resistance, wait, it's only two, right?
Yeah, that I can do.
Um, water and bucket get stained.
Uh, this one did washing surface.
Increases tool ability to clean difficult stains.
we'll still do the tool stand by 30 percent bigger number is
always better right all right now this bad boy can go like
right here oh so watch this now this guy goes here so he's
always okay and everything's clean so then we so then we'll
clean we run here we go do and then we can start doing it
yes yes oh I forgot to get the other one watch this okay yes
the method has been figured out oh my god it's getting the
staying so easily now.
Yes!
Oh, my bad.
She's braining.
Hoi!
Alright.
Then we go back in.
Look how fast it cleans.
Holy canola!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, we're super speedy.
cleaning is my passion me too buddy they call me the janitor
oh i was about to say is that everything in here
no procedure finished yay
i'm gonna grab you now and we're gonna take you into here
okay Enjoy enjoy the music
All right Something is blocking the way what's blocking the
way
Could be these we have that evidence as well Put you up
Something is blocking the way
Put these away as well.
We're just going one room at a time.
Is it the trash?
Maybe it's a ducky.
Don't break, don't break.
Okay.
Yeah.
Just a little bit more.
Just this big stain.
Which is a whole lot of nothing now.
And...
This little guy.
And easy.
And then let's collect this.
Maybe this...
Okay, wait.
Okay, so one girl thought he was proposing.
One girl thought he was two-timing.
And one girl thinks he wants to dump her.
Hmm.
What stain?
Exactly.
Oh, I body blocked it.
Oh, I was body blocking the one in the way.
No, no, no.
There was just no stain.
Did we get everything in here then?
I guess so.
It says clean up all the trash.
Oh wait, there's a guy here.
Oh, that's all this stuff here.
Done that.
Anything else?
You're telling me this does not open and reveal money and
secrets?
What's the tricycle for?
yeah what's staying what oh wait you know I just realized
okay we'll move it later
the tricycle wants to play a game jigsaw what they got you
know some people hire like strippers that are like
firefighters and other people hire strippers that our
jigsaw.
Get rid of the trash.
What trash is left?
Oh.
Maybe my bag of trash.
No, it can't be.
No, it still says get rid of the trash.
It's true.
This one, no standing on top.
Gamers don't look up.
Look at that!
Okay, we did the cabins.
Nice!
Nice, nice, nice!
It's not like totally clean though.
It still looks like something happened here, you know?
Okay, so that's like half the property ish.
Is there a body in here?
Might as well be.
Good golly.
I need to clear the way first.
What's wrong?
What's in the way?
There we go.
Oh.
What's this?
One's never too old to have fun, huh?
Wee!
Oh my gosh.
You remember that guy that was like...
He was on TV.
He had a fetish for like inflatables and stuff.
He would like go crazy in this room.
He'd be like...
You know?
Wait, should I have him...
Oh wait, I didn't... I didn't finish...
Wait.
I actually can't get out.
Please.
Wait, no!
I should have never inflated!
No, I mean...
Up to 99% of harmful particles from the air.
Wait, no!
How am I supposed to clean it?
I messed up.
Beer.
How?
I don't remember that.
Minto, why are you watching TLC?
Well, I don't watch it anymore.
I had an old roommate, though.
She and I, we would, like, watch 90 Day Fiancé, though.
We would watch that together.
But I have another friend!
She's, like, she's, like, crazy for those shows.
island those ones I don't really get is there a is there a
way to please pizza pizza move there is none okay we'll find
it we'll find a way to shoot hit the button to drain it
again is it really so simple oh you're right Oh, I can't.
Okay.
Because in other...
Okay, the reason I was like so scared by it was because in
other areas there was like a...
You couldn't just hit the button.
It was like something else, you know?
That you had to do.
It was like a wheel that you had to turn.
I was terrified.
Yeah, I was so scared.
How do you move up to 99% of harmful particles from here?
Good job.
Party popper!
Imagine this being your death soundtrack.
I hope mine was like cute mowing music.
Where is the...
You son of a...
Monkey paw girls.
Um...
Oh gosh, that guy's body scared me.
Okay.
A rave-full of dead people.
A rave-yard.
A rave-yard!
You're so clever.
That's my cleaner.
A rave-yard.
Why didn't I think of that?
I hate when people are funnier than me.
Plus two.
I knew you guys would do that.
I knew you guys would plus two him.
You've never plus twoed me before.
Ew!
All right, let's go get our buckets.
Bucket of cleaning and bucket of soap.
All right, careful.
This is the one we don't want to spill.
Careful.
We'll put it here for now.
I think I will turn off the music, though.
Sorry.
Sorry to everybody enjoying the rave.
That's not true.
Make a joke, watch.
Your mom?
I don't know.
I'm a hut.
I'm...
I'm in a rut.
You can't just tell me to tell a joke.
You can't just...
I can't just do it.
I'm not a...
I'm not a little monkey for your entertainment.
Plus two.
Don't plus two that.
Yeah.
Dang, you got me.
I did, didn't I?
VTuber, be funny.
Oh, God, that's literally my job.
I'm having such pressure.
I'm having pressure.
Oh, my God.
Curious charge me, Super.
I know you're a little minke for entertainment.
Oh,
I sounded like a little bulldog.
Have you guys ever heard, like, bulldog sometimes?
They're terrifying.
Like, when they get really excited, they go, like...
See more things for the plus two.
Yeah, I have one!
No way!
It's so funny.
It makes me concerned because I'm, like, they okay but it's
also oops so funny wow whoo-ha whoo-ha
that's why you shouldn't do especially frenchies yes any
drugs for that matter oh my gosh he's our he's my anti-drug
mr kovalski this put this guy in schools you'd be like if
you've seen the things that i've seen you'd never want to
touch a drug ever I'll make sure you don't want to touch a
drug.
I've seen...
I've seen everything.
Oh, shit.
I've seen things you never thought you'd see.
He already works at a school.
Wait, you're right, he's the school janitor.
They won't even give him a raise.
But look how I've seen... I've seen your work.
Mr. Kovalski, I'm thoroughly impressed.
Oh, disgusting.
Oh, it's dirty, that's why.
The whole mission is an anti-drug PSA.
Exactly.
That's what I'm saying.
You'd be like, you don't know.
You don't want to know.
It won't move like this.
You don't want to know what I've seen.
I've seen ghost cats.
You think any of your school janitors growing up had a cool
side gig like this?
I don't know, probably.
I didn't really know any of my janitors, you know.
I did have a...
Whoa, that was cool.
I did have a bus driver once, though, because she got fired
because she would let the kids drive the bus.
I always thought it was...
I never did it.
But then somebody was like, yeah!
She let me drive the bus!
And then we never saw her again.
make sense what if you like are driven by a kid that you
think is like really not going to be a good driver you know
what I mean whoops there we go that would end a career
pretty sure then oh come on I just stabbed why do you hate
me stay in vegetables don't eat drugs don't do school to
school for cool right boys and girls right kids saw the new
ace combat online trailer it's maybe so excited i haven't
watched it yet okay i'll have to watch it after this also i
saw some kind of metal gear looking enemy target what do
they mean by this what do you mean by that what do you mean
not what do you mean a
weapon to
Guys, I messed up...
I messed up our thing!
I messed it up!
It's okay, we have more detergent.
Be careful.
What did I do?
Strength.
And...
We just need to...
We don't get a grip.
Okay.
I'm gripped.
Uh, let's get our Izonator right in here.
All right, back into the pool.
Wait, did I suds these?
Suds them.
They must be thoroughly sudsed.
Wait, I'll clean it first.
Every time I move, I hear something else break.
I can't catch a break, if you know what I mean.
Yeah, we're just too strong.
I'm like a dang giant in here.
I'm Frankenstein.
Actually, I don't know my own strength.
What is the plus two for?
Time I have to clean blood out of a pool.
I'd have two dollars.
Oops.
Oh, we almost got all the blood out here, though.
Oh.
This is at least the third time.
Yay!
We've got all the blood!
Yahoo!
Okay, there's no garbage in here.
We'll refill the pool.
Because why not?
Garbage?
My garbage.
Oh, wait, these count as garbage?
These count as trash?
Oh.
Nice.
And, uh...
Okay, we got a lot of chairs.
Oh, all these kegs!
Okay, okay, okay.
Thank you.
Put you over there.
Put you...
Uh...
Right there.
Nice.
Okay.
There's like a million of these around.
Ah!
Luckily, I don't think any of these have blood on them.
Oh, is that money?
Is that money?
No, it's garbage.
Wait, can I not grab it because it's underneath this chair?
Grab it, thank you.
Alright.
Okay.
Oh, and there's more here even.
This is fine.
We collect everything.
I'm the garbage man.
Bowman.
Should have been me.
What, collecting the garbage?
You want my job?
I didn't ask for this.
You think I chose to play this?
You think...
You think it's so easy coming in here and swinging my
detergent and my mobs around and everything?
You think you could do this?
I'd like to see you try
Quite a few more chairs It's all garbage down here Meantos
Yeah, you're telling me
Did that make it in?
Yeah I saw more But am I crazy?
Maybe they're inside Okay Or there was a...
Wasn't there one over here or something?
Yeah, this one right here.
I was gonna say, I know I saw another one.
There we go.
Can't wait to...
Evo you.
They got the 6-7 Evo.
Why?
The Game Lobby supports up to 100 players?
Holy cow.
it's gonna be so much fun well i'll play well i'll play all
right let's clean up all the garbage in here now oh my gosh
look it like it like blended in did you see that there
we go nice it like fell down the stairs and then blended in
all right there's a lot of garbage in here okay
Okay.
All right.
Oh yeah.
Can't pick up anything with a full bag.
Okay.
A hundred sinks six sevens.
You know what?
Maybe I won't play.
I'm just kidding.
You know what?
Maybe.
Maybe we're fine.
How did this guy get pinned though?
That's crazy.
Oh, they did.
thought they were they were trying to get the apple right
and they got his neck
there's so much going on in this place it's actually crazy
let's see here
everybody be making lemons and strawberries that's my kind
of meal give me a new enemy oh whoops that's not what i
meant to do i meant to do that okay all right what else i
feel like garbage on is could be like a last thing okay
let's bring in actually wait hold on let's bring in you very
carefully put you right by the door right okay and now scrub
it up
that one i just chose to ignore i just understand a woman
counting is hard what is that supposed
I had a substitute bus driver who kids asked, can we smoke?
She was like, you can do anything except get laid.
Lots of kids lit it up.
What?
Parents called to complain.
Driver radioed the bus garage while driving back and was
like, oh, I think someone was smoking.
Next day.
Huh?
Regular bus driver went, I heard someone smoked.
Who was it?
And kids were like, who wasn't?
Subdriver was banned from the district.
That's crazy.
Wait, that's actually crazy.
My bus driver, she just like, I don't know, got really
excited.
She would be like, yeah, I'm just going to let you guys, she
would let, like, she wouldn't let them push the pedals.
But she would let the kids steer the bus, like with the
wheel.
So I guess it could be worse.
Ours let us do anything but smoke on the bus.
I think it's probably better that you don't let the kids
smoke on the bus.
I think maybe that's an activity you should discourage from
the children, you know?
Just maybe...
I'm not a bus driver.
I've never been thanked as one.
I've never been thought of as one, you know?
But if I were a bus driver, I think I would...
would say maybe the kids don't smoke here.
I knew that was going to happen.
Someone sprayed pepper spray on our bus.
What the heck?
You guys are going to some crazy schools.
Some crazy places.
It won't move like this.
Does that have blood on it or is it just that color.
You can't tell.
There we go.
It won't move like this.
Is it you?
Yes.
I don't always understand the logic behind the items in the
way but it's fine, I guess.
Okay.
The candlestick holder goes here.
Yeah, the heaviest solo cup of all time.
Oh, this guy got shot in the leg!
Did he like bleed out?
Oh, oops.
My bad.
Is that what- Oh, dang it.
Is that what happened?
Arrow to the knee.
More like a- to the shin, but yeah.
He used to be an adventurer too.
Why did that like become such a meme?
why that line is it just because it sounds funny like I know
it's in Skyrim you would hear it so much oh okay okay so
it's kind of like with oblivion where they're like stop you
have violated the law
let's see where did this go anyway ah here they were
spamming it whoops whoa whoa
we'll do this that was
a that was a bolt move they still hit the apple though
that's pretty good nice are you satisfied now Robin Hood
sheesh second try though who knows it could have been the
first try It could have been the first try.
And then, I don't know.
There's still some things I need to move back, huh?
Move furniture back to its place.
Something there.
I didn't grab before.
Watch this.
Oh, that was actually so close.
Wait.
That could have been my moment!
Wait!
That should have been my moment.
We were so close.
Oh, there's some chairs here.
And one more, one more keg.
Barrel?
Whatever it is.
Oh, we need this first.
Ew.
Okay.
I was pitting him to the floor.
He must have tried to sleep through the pain.
an alcohol to get through the pain sounded like it went in
there's a chair in the pool oh is there I don't know all
right that's all of our bodies uh is there one I don't I
don't think I remember wait no I'll drain it just in case
but I I don't remember seeing one.
Oh, it's floating!
Oh, I thought...
Oh, that would make more sense, huh?
Thank you, guys.
It's over here.
Okay.
Well, I needed to drain it anyway to get it out, so cool.
Maybe we'll find the rest.
Oh, my gosh.
Of course, there's stuff on the ceiling.
Gamers don't look up.
I knew that was going to happen and I didn't care.
I let it happen anyway.
That was fast.
A rubber duckies are a reference to plastic duck simulator.
I think they could just be rubber duckies.
I have no idea.
If you believe that, Then do it.
There are reference to Jeep drivers.
I think it's kind of cute.
The ducky thing.
I'm like, oh, they have like a little sense of community.
I need to clear the way first.
But I've also seen some people get like stupidly aggressive
about it.
They're like, don't put a damn duck on my Jeep.
I hate those stinking ducks.
I don't want a damn dark fruit in my vibe That's literally
what they say
I didn't realize it was controversial I don't know Maybe if
you Oh Oh Oh,
I put out the light.
Oh, there's some evidence here.
Who cares?
That's what their name is?
Tomorrow, lots.
Where are you, mate?
Now listen, this ain't some weak shit.
This is some new line of product.
It will F you up.
Okay.
Crying.
Crying, face.
This answer certainly explains itself.
Yes, it do.
Not the strong drugs that make you cry.
Can I...
Oh, nice!
I was about to say, though, can I use the sponge with the
detergent?
Oh, it's like a silly face!
Did you guys see it?
I messed it up.
Oh, oh my god, he's eating it.
And then he's gonna eat me.
Oh my god!
Look at all that cash.
So-called party trick.
Oh!
I can get it.
Nice.
No?
Oh my god.
Don't do it.
Please.
I can't breathe on it.
Oh, it's stabilized.
It's stabilized.
We're fine.
Yes.
we're so good we're too good
a mansion with nothing in its drawers did they rent this did
they rent this to seem cool to their friends you know so
people will do that like tiktokers and stuff they'll rent
the houses and they'll be like this is my house but it's not
their house they rented it is there a body in the fridge it
wouldn't let me open the fridge but we did get all the
bodies, luckily.
Move furniture back to its place.
We still have a couple left.
And I've found no secrets.
Oh.
The Bible.
God was not present at this party.
Chair and chandelier.
Oh my God, you're actually right.
I didn't notice it.
That sounds like such a ridiculous thing.
I didn't see it at all.
It says the Bible.
It does?
No, it says the Bible!
The Holy Bible.
They'd be thinking about that Rome Empire.
Um.
Okay, nothing in here.
There's like so much optional stuff in this one that it
feels like you end up not cleaning so much.
Oh yeah, okay.
There's a couple of chairs that we need to find.
Lamp and Bibble Room.
Ah, thank you.
Okay, the party house has been cleaned.
Nice.
Alright, so that's that.
So now let's go find...
I think it's just these two chairs.
or one chair oh and one okay i don't think i saw that in
here double checking no the barrel
uh-huh those are not the chairs we are one one thing
The bubble is an Aquatine Hunger Force reference.
You guys are so old.
Oh, here's one.
Here's one.
I knew.
I had seen.
Chair in the flower beds by the stairs.
Really?
Thank you.
She's not wrong.
Ah!
Yeah!
Everything.
Wait, but I had no secrets.
Or I found one secret.
It doesn't feel like that's it.
Hope Star Rotor is as old.
Okay, see that?
No talking to the ducks again.
They really don't want you talking to them, huh?
yeah strong beds eternal so true
we made it we made it through this one was a toughie it was
so many so many things there's two secrets on this map okay
so we got one for sure the second secret does anyone know if
they know May I have a hint?
The ducks know too much.
These guys.
Complete the coven?
Am I missing a...
Oh.
Look at it!
Look at me!
Did I mess it up?
Hmm.
Wait, is that...
Is that a different color?
Oh, he is.
He's a white duck.
We need a purple duck.
It's not duck-related?
Oh.
Wait, then why was everybody saying about the ducks?
Nobody knows what they're talking about.
White.
Something to do with that.
It's a secret place near where you asked for a hint.
Now do I do?
Was it something to do with this thing?
Or...
Maybe this is destroyable.
This wood in here.
You can crawl under.
Oh wait?
What is this?
Whoa!
Oh, I'm stuck.
I'm actually stuck.
Oh, there we go.
single ladies witness the tragic love story one doctor let
the dark ritual combine to bring forth a creature most foul
oh that's why he was acting funny he was he was proposing
the answer is what the BF the yeah what the boyfriend was to
he wasn't gonna propose to my lovely Anne from the moment I
laid eyes on you my heart has been a ticking time bomb
counting down to an inevitable explosion of love I can
barely contain the intense feelings that surge through me
every time I see your smile it's as if there's a spark that
ignites a firestorm within me your presence is like dynamite
powerful and captivating everything is bomb related
capable of turning my world upside down in the most
delightful way being apart from you feels like defusing a
bomb with no instructions
Is his job like a bomb diffuser?
Because otherwise, this is like concerning levels of
thinking of explosives.
It's unbearable and nerve-wracking.
I crave your touch, your laughter, your everything.
And when we're together, I feel a rush that's more powerful
than any explosion.
So here I am confessing my love for you.
Yours truly, Tom.
Well, Anne kind of sucked, so...
He raised his own flags, for real.
Alright, yay!
We did it!
Kaboom!
Rest in peace, my Thomas got hit by a bazooka.
Man's went out with a bang, yeah.
So many signs.
no one to care wait so many signs about what what do you
why'd you say that
i'm not 100 no one hour and 15 i think that was our longest
yeah wow
nice you want to see my reaction to the next place i was
probably gonna call it but we can We'll go into it.
We'll see what it's like first.
Give me the skill points, please.
Oh, yeah.
12 points.
Nice, nice, nice.
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah.
End of mission.
Yeah, we'll take a little sneak peek.
Nice.
Alright.
Dukes!
But you're still a good boy.
Oh, Dexter.
You're my boy.
What do we take?
We took it.
Oh messed up All the bills.
Oh my bad.
I didn't mean to punch the bills.
I knew I could count on you My daughter always gets into
trouble and makes some kind of mess That's when I come in
handy the greatest dead in the world, but I'm sure you know
our daughters are don't you he must think we're the same but
surely we're not unlike him i don't have any other choice or
do i what do you mean by that what do you mean by that but
also if this guy liked us so much i feel like he would help
with our bills you know he'd be like wow kovalski you've
been my best man i'm gonna get your daughter out of the
Because then it would be even more that we feel indebted to
him.
You know what I mean?
Oh, dog just loaded in.
Oh, wow.
Oh.
One last touch.
Are you imagining Big Jim Kovowski BL?
No.
But did you know there's like that new Coyote versus Acme
movie?
like with with wow the coyote and roadrunner it's like it
makes me want to watch it he's like yearning for him so hard
oh he's like he i want to say it nothing stopping you no i
will watch it wow our place looks so good our place looks so
good wow nice oh we're enjoying nice outside except mission
from my computer minky he wants roadrunner dead no he
doesn't no he doesn't that's the thing it's a batman joker
situation they need each other they thrive off of each other
after all what value is there in a hunter without prey.
Exactly!
I did not get that from the trailer.
You have to!
I mean, I haven't even watched it, but I've seen.
I've seen!
Like Tom and Jerry.
Oh, it's delicious.
Oh my god.
You're scaring me every time, wife.
Get out of here.
Now, this is looking like a dad's cave.
that we've got a rug!
I'm feeling better!
Hi, Dad.
I wanted to let you know I'm starting to feel better.
The doctors say the treatment is working, and I've been able
to get out of bed more often.
I even joined in on a group activity today, and it was fun.
It felt good to laugh again.
I still have to take it easy, but it's nice to see some
progress.
I can't wait to come home and spend time with you and
Dexter.
I miss you both every day.
Love you.
Yes, our crimes.
Our crimes are paying off.
Holy it's like the biggest size yet I believe that after the
last VIP event my art gallery requires your cleaning
services we use the entire building so I might need some
work lots of people involved once you arrive you will
understand what I mean this time not everything went
according to plan I can't risk making any more mistakes I'm
already in trouble with some important people so I'm hoping
you can help me clean up this mess.
Tey.
Not Pedro rascal.
My favorite level?
Alright, let's, uh, we'll accept it.
I'm not gonna do this one right now because it will probably
take me over an hour again.
But, I do wanna see it because everyone's hyping it up.
I wanna see what it's like.
I'm hungry for dinner, though.
some nana everyone loves this level yeah right getting
serious flags from the daughter don't say that no oh the
skill tree it's okay it's okay because we're not doing it
it's fine seeing with my own eyes what these billionaires
use their money for was disgusting while some of us are
trying to make ends meet others find pleasure in some
gruesome fun gruesome world really is just a playground for
rich what's for dinner i don't know maybe spaghetti kind of
craving tacos too though lately good luck and good night
cleaning artists reporting for duty the east wing well look
at that view right there oh oh no he's missing a job that
none of them came here to admire the art
Wait, this is...
Why is he...
Oh, that's a picture.
Oh my gosh!
Whoa.
What is this?
West Wing.
I can't even see where the bodies are because there's...
We're just all over the place.
What is that?
Whoa.
Whoa!
Wait, is that a real person?
Or...
Oh.
Garbage band.
My bad.
Oh.
Oh, this is where we started.
Whoa.
Garbage band.
Praise.
the duck Lord what is happening an
illusion of choice an illusion of choice what's behind door
number one nothing oh oh the bathroom it's not how it
usually works oh well I won't grab anything right now
because again we're just seeing what the place is like I'm
just exploring I'm getting it all out of the way.
I'm confused what the party was.
I'm trying to figure that out.
Why are the bathroom doors hidden in the art?
Because it's art, it's not meant for us.
We're stupid people.
We don't know anything.
Who's in one of these?
We're stupid people.
We know nothing.
How could we ever understand?
Anybody...
else would obviously know.
Why are there so many...
Why are there no... Why are there chair...
I can't stop saying why.
I can't stop asking why.
I'm excited to do this one next time.
I know I'm like...
Oh, you.
You.
Fuck you.
Yeah!
So true!
What a dumb exhibition.
I'm so confused.
Oh, that's kind of freaky.
Wow.
Was there a door over here?
Oh, no.
Just serial experiments lane.
What?
There's...
Well?
Cool place.
I'm excited to do it next time.
But there's a secret song with the squeaking ducks.
Oh, yeah.
We're going to try for that.
sure next time one second
never mind looking forward to some dino fun time have a good
meal thank you yeah oh look at his little eyes i'm gonna be
kind of super busy chaotic workday but this was so relaxing
thanks for watching the stress away i feel cleansed also i'm
so happy that you're moving forward the kitty yeah oh my
gosh i wanted to talk about it though like they asked me a
million and one questions and i was like I was like, okay.
And I had been to the adoption location before.
But they were like, which kitty do you want?
And I was like, well, can you like help me?
Why?
Can you help me like pick one out?
And then they were like, was there anyone that got your eye?
And I was like, well, I liked this guy.
And they were like, oh, he's great.
But he's a bonded cat.
And I don't know if I can take on like, you know, two
adoption.
the moment um but then they were like oh no he's not and i
was like but then did somebody adopt him without his buddy
like that's so sad so i don't know i'm i'm waiting to hear
back with more info because that would be the saddest thing
oh my gosh there's so much and we got unlocked another
The game has ended.
I hope things work out, too.
I'm sure they will, you know.
But shouldn't they be off limits?
So yeah.
It's just a little, like...
Just trying to figure it out.
I tweeted my dumb looking...
Oh, dumb looking for 35-year-old Fujo Comet and a BL company
owning Fujo offered me husband slot 36.
What did I get myself into?
What
does that mean?
Are you part of the Yowie?
Or
36 husbands?
Who's the 35?
Who the other 35?
I didn't forget about the shirt I'm just confused about what
they're offering very very interesting yeah we've got like a
squid game thing going on here for sure I
will head out now oh thank you so much we will do all of
this area next time Next time, next time.
And, yeah.
Thanks for letting me a crime scene clean again.
This game is so relaxing.
I like it a lot.
Fake news.
Thank you!
Ultimito, everybody!
Ita-da-shan!
La la la!
No cannibalism!
We are cured!
Bye-bye!
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye.
Have a good day, have a good night.
Have a good time, Joan.
Bye-bye, bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye.
Bye